[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
January and Vicon Zay the Netherlands
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun shoulder back
just playing a modern brilliancy there
it is a sensational moment
once again vikon Zay starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps when eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back can the world champion demonstrate
that resilience which has accompanied
him for his entire chess career the
world's number one looks to further
cement his legacy in this event and the
game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish is
taking down
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom
Magnus won here as a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps big
results
manages his first win
the Dutch referred to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mine Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
[Music]
welcome ladies and gentlemen to round
six of the 85th edition of the Tata
steel chess tournament
2023 this is going to be an epic
exciting round as this storied and
historic tournament reaches its halfway
point happy Friday everybody no better
way to spend our Friday than to watch
the world champion and others can test
round six of Tata steel I'm your host
Grand Master Daniel nerdinski alongside
me today once again International Master
Ivanka Huska yovi welcome to the show
are you as excited as I am yeah
absolutely thrilled to be here I mean
because judging by yesterday's games we
were in for a treat we were absolutely
spoiled so many Sensational results I
can't wait to see what's going to happen
today
if it's anything like yesterday we are
most certainly in for a barn burner and
there's a guy pretty obscure character
named vishwanath and Anand who is in
attendance for his let me say 22nd trip
to waikansei no I did not misspeak 22nd
trip to the seaside resort town and for
the first time as a spectator so let's
start uh by listening in as the Press
caught up with Vichy to discuss why this
tournament means so much to the Chess
World here we go there's been a lot of
fun uh action in both groups and um I
think it's a great tournament but I
think this tournament
stays relevant because it has this
unique format because it's large enough
14 players that you can accommodate a
mixture of playing Styles and playing
strings and I think that creates its own
um energy because you get a lot more
dynamism and people take more risks
against each other so if you only have
the top group that develops into a
certain kind of relationship I think
this format is one of the reasons that I
can say is the only only traditional
tournament which is still going so
strong and it's because of this angle
that it's still a very interesting tone
would follow it's a classical tournament
that everyone waits for the whole year
round
oh man Vichy Anand in attendance and he
really emphasizes this eclectic playing
field you've got so many different
Generations yo you've got players at
different stages of their career in both
the Challenger and the master section
and we saw that play out so clearly on
Thursday yesterday yeah absolutely and
that we can see yesterday's results and
the first thing that stands out was that
Magnus Carlson lost with the white
pieces against young Uzbek Talent
Norbeck
and that was just an incredible game by
the young teenager and there we can see
that it is Abdul satarov who tops the
leaderboard with four points out of five
that is a remarkable score I mean
absolutely unheard of and then we have
Anish Gary on three and a half points
out of five and the niche has been on
fire I mean he's played some spectacular
chess
and yesterday he drew against a young
pregnantanda and other notable response
results was that Levon aronian kicked
off his first win against the young
Vincent kaimer
yeah that was such a nice Grind game we
thought Vincent had the draw in the bag
and then all of a sudden out of a clear
blue sky Lavonne finds a way to break
Vincent's Fortress and the final
decisive game was Max sudlu's very
smooth win over uh Jordan van Forest the
2021 Edition winner on the heels of some
incredible opening preparation so Parham
makes his way back to 50 but you know
the storyline of the tournament apart
from Notre back's incredible performance
is of course Magnus Carlson's tournament
position he is on minus one he sits on
two out of five you might not find him
if you look for him in the top half of
the tournament cross stable where he
sits about 99 of the time Magnus has
some coming back to do and he's gonna
try to start today let's review the
pairings that we have today Magnus
Carlson has the black pieces against a
somewhat off-form Jordan van Forest who
nonetheless is incredibly difficult to
defeat with the black pieces and of of
course Yogi Abdul Satora progdananda is
really the Marky matchup of the day
isn't it yeah absolutely I mean these
guys they're so close in age and that
must mean that they are Rivals and so
I'm expecting a very fierce battle here
because this is going to be a matter of
Pride who is going to be the next young
Challenger to magnus's well to the world
champions Throne I mean I can't wait for
today another matchup that really
catches my eye it's going to be Wesley
so against Vincent kymer now the reason
I say this is because Wesley actually
said in an interview yesterday that this
has been his worst start ever in tatters
deals and uh he's not happy he wants to
win a game
well five draws this is worst star that
he hasn't had a lot of bad starts I
would like one of Wesley's bad starts in
a tournament that I play and of course
we've got I'm just a tour of Prague this
is an opportunity for Notre back to
extend his lead and Bernice Geary who
sits on three and a half out of five
clear second well he's got the white
pieces he's gonna have to take some
risks I mean at this point in the
tournament given the form that Notre
back has showed you have to exploit
games of the white pieces and Argent era
guys he feels like he hasn't lost a game
in ages but he's come pretty close to
this tournament hasn't he yeah he has he
has been riding his luck somewhat but
that's because the positions he's been
getting are so sharp I mean yesterday's
battle between ding Loren and Arjun
eragasi was just none other than a
roller coaster one side was winning then
the evaluation just flipped it was
Madness on the board and uh I'm
expecting if Anish wants to take risks
against someone Arjun is your guy he'll
be up for that challenge oh he will be
he absolutely will be I'm expecting a
sharp opening maybe like the one we saw
in anisha's incredible win over good
cash and as we see the players taking
their seats and the spectators and press
Milling about let's take one quick look
at the format and the time control so we
make sure that we are all on the same
page the time control historically in
tata steel is incredibly generous
there's a lot of additional time the
players start with 100 minutes for 40
moves after move 40 is executed they
earn an additional 50 minutes or the
next 20 moves and on move 60 they
receive a final time edition of 15
minutes for the rest of the game and of
course there is the traditional 30
second increment 30 seconds added to
your clock after each move is made Tata
steel is a marathon event 13 Rounds are
contested it is a round robin the time
control leads to some seven sometimes
even eight hour games Yogi and most
famously that is still produces some
highest quality chess that we see in any
super tournament each year and as vishi
pointed out that's part of the reason
why everybody looks forward to this this
storied event as we wait or the round
six handshake
yeah and uh for me vike is all about the
characters it's all about the Fighting
Chess and it's also about the quality as
you said and I love the fact that the
players do get an increment after every
move I kind of think of it like bonus
time you know you get that 30 second
pause a moment to catch your breath and
then you can adjust the situation in
front of you and there we see the
players The Challengers and the Masters
getting ready there we see Jordan van
Forest he is going to be meeting Magnus
Carlson he has the white pieces and
Jordan of course he is like a Maverick
when it comes to opening he has all
sorts of original creative ideas in fact
that's why Magnus employed him as part
of his team in the world championship
match of 2021 against against Napoleon
I'm getting my years blurred up you know
it was 2021.
I mean I I feel like I don't remember
the month the day the year anymore ever
ever since covet started but Jordan men
forest does not earn the world champions
Praise by accident Magnus Carlson does
not hire people a part of his opening
team by accident and I'm very curious to
see what opening the world champion is
going to play Jordan is primarily an E4
player and there we go ladies and
gentlemen round six of Tata steel has
kicked off with one E4 by Jordan van
Forrest Magnus I don't think is going to
play a Berlin he might play iru Lopez
Yobe but in response to Bishop B5 I
would expect some sort of sideline he is
playing this game for a win the
tournament situation is exceptional for
him and not in a good way as in an
exception to the rule and he has to
start winning fast if he wants to
re-emerge at the top half of the
tournament cross table Yeah and we see a
pause maybe Magnus getting ready or
playing mind games and I agree with you
I do not think we're gonna see the move
E5 on the board I suspect that we're
gonna see a zillion something Cutthroat
something which encourages Jordan to
play in his aggressive style and that's
how Magnus can catch him in the
counter-attack and Magnus keeping us
waiting and we got it right
you got it right I'm giving you the
credit C5 incredible yeah but now this
is the moment of truth I mean we're
going to see an open Sicilian for short
night F3 and uh is Magnus gonna play
Knight C6 and are we gonna see a repeat
of the smashnikov that the players have
battled in
Magnus really one of the the last
remaining proponents of the svashnikov
the problem is that white does a fair
share of variations that don't quite
lead to a four-straw but come pretty
darn close and E6 I would go so far as
to say a rare guest a relatively rare
guests these days in top level chess are
we going to see it say manov or are we
going to see a good old-school con where
black plays an early A6 I would imagine
he's gonna play the taemon off here was
Knight C6 I was gonna say that I haven't
seen the car on a top level
forever yes oh yeah I mean I'm trying to
and there you go you called it Knight C6
on the board no one has played the card
maybe that's the next challenge to our
our guy's name play calm we want to see
new ideas there and okay Knight C6 on
the board I'm I'm predicting the night
will come out to C3
and there you go
so far so good
there was no way Jordan expected this I
mean I would probably imagine that
Jordan prepared for E4 E5 but preparing
against Magnus Carlson especially when
you have no idea what frame of mind he
is in is virtually impossible because of
how vast this repertoire is so Queen C7
in this position is the continuation of
the taimana there are some Sidelines
here you could play the immediate A6 or
you could play the four Knight Sicilian
and get your knight out to F6 but I'm
pretty sure Magnus is going Queen C7 and
man oh man is Jordan armed to the teeth
against the Sicilian so we're in for a
good old school bloodbath here yeah
can't wait I mean but uh we do know
magnus's mindset actually we know that
Magnus he will be raging he would be
wanting to take down Jordan today I mean
he cannot afford
to play it safe I mean it's just not
magnus's style is it you know because
normally when you lose two games in a
row or you're having a bad tournament
everyone is like wow just steady the
ship take a draw play as solidly as you
can well we know Magnus he can't do that
he's the world number one he has to
start notching up those points and the
Timon is on the board the Queen has come
out
indeed it has in the Jordan with a vast
array of options here ranging from G3
to Bishop E3 to Bishop E2 as he develops
his light skirt Bishop one square to the
left and that is rather peaceful Line
This is this has existed really since
the Sicilian became popular generally
other Bishop comes out to E3 and with
this move Jordan signals his intention
to Castle kingside leading to relatively
speaking a more peaceful position
although even with both sides Castle to
the same side of the board the situation
can explode on the king side it doesn't
mean that white relinquishes his
attacking Ambitions but you'll be just
to Echo your point completely and your
minus two in a tournament you're usually
doing damage control the world champion
has always has the responsibility
essentially to play to win the
tournament even when he sits at minus
one halfway through the tournament so
Magnus still very much entertaining
hopes of launching a comeback guess what
if he wins three games in a row which
has happened before you think about
Magnuson plus one with three or four
rounds left he puts himself in position
so not all all hope is not lost for the
world champion yet and he knows that
yeah and talking about damage control I
do think that Jordan is playing quite
solidly he just wants to Coast home and
take a point any kind of points and
there we see the knights leave the board
I'm predicting Magnus will try to
unbalance the pawn structure by
capturing that Knight with the B Pawn uh
I don't think any other options
oh
yeah not accepted right you mean you
just gotta take that night with the pawn
but Magnus is hesitating
ah don't keep us guessing
1986. but that's got to be a little bit
more Uncommon than castle and kingside
which is what Magnus must have accepted
uh expected now D takes C6 as weird as
it seems to capture away from the center
I have seen certain Sicilian players
display an affinity for that line
generally the way the black follows it
up is by playing e65 and opening up a
diagonal for the light squared Bishop
but you made a good point about Magnus
trying to unbalance the game why are you
playing the Sicilian if you're then
essentially going to force the game into
a symmetrical Pawn structure and you
might have as well played E5 so I think
Magnus is choosing between Queen takes
Knight and BC and maybe he's just
adjusting himself to this unexpected
move and trying to remember his opening
files yeah probably and like you say
again I was checking the opening
databases and you're right the most
popular move wasn't to capture that
night it was just simply to Castle
develop a piece even take a claim in the
center by pushing the F Pawn forwards
and this I think is the seventh choice
in the database so yeah Magnus uh
definitely thinking about what to do and
I agree it's going to be captured with
the queen or capture with the B Pawn and
uh
I'm I'm just I would catch up with a
with the pawn and uh stake a claim in
the center with D5 and then continue the
game and one thing I have noticed about
magnus's game is that he really likes a
good one structure by good point
structure I mean all the pawns defending
themselves I mean a structure where it's
easy to play it's easy to navigate a
breakthrough and easy to position his
pieces on good squares
um but the fact that he's hesitating
makes me think
he might surprise me and capture that
night with the queen he's he's probably
thinking see I remember why I hired
Jordan van Forest he seems to have nasty
prep in every line and whenever you face
an unexpected move a move that you know
to be rare you're always immediately
posed with this dilemma do you try to
steer the game away from what your
opening opponent is probably going to
expect in this case b takes C6 but that
comes at the risk of making a second or
third right move or do you essentially
go all in you go down what you know to
be the main line but then you risk
running into some sort of a novelty or
some some sort of incredibly nasty
preparation where your opponent is far
more acquainted with the resulting
position than you are so Magnus already
might be experiencing a good deal of
frustration here like I can't seem to
avoid my opponent's prep can anything go
right for me in this tournament in the
world champion about to make a move
there as you see him on the top right of
your screen on his stakeable
weight just that he sits and everything
about the world champion is just
trademarked
[Laughter]
I mean you make a great point that
actually when it comes to the opening
because it's all about those Mind Games
it's all about whether you trust your
opening knowledge or whether you try to
vary and as you say play something a
little bit different
um I have to say when it comes to my
personal opinion and my personal choice
it depends on the rating of my opponents
and that's something actually that these
guys in I can say don't probably have
the Liberty because if I'm playing
someone weaker than myself I'm like yeah
okay fine I am gonna vary and I'm gonna
trust that my understanding is better if
I'm playing someone much higher rated
than me I will be like no no no no no no
I trust myself
[Laughter]
um they I mean it just depends it really
does depend but these guys are the
finest players in the world and if
they're not the finest players in the
world they are the most talented Juniors
who are under rated dangerous in every
sense of the word oh I would not envy
being in Magnus issues here I would like
yes I have the confession to make
despite me writing a book on the opening
the opening is my least favorite
favorite part of Chess I prefer the
middle game for the end game anything
but the opening too much
now you're speaking a language that I
understand and you do have some great
opening books I think on the Karo Khan
and others but you know you I feel a
similar way about the end game I've
written a book on the end game but it
has not made the end game any less it
has not demystified the end game in my
eyes at all and sometimes people assume
that I just know the keys to the kingdom
far from in fact that I think after I
wrote the book I even got worse because
I don't practice what I preach but as
the world champion contemplates with
which piece to recapture the Knight on
C6 I think this is a great opportunity
for us to pay our first visit of the day
to our bird's eye view a look at all of
the games as they currently stand you
can see Magnus Carlson's game uh right
in the middle of your screen top left we
have Wesley so and a rue Lopez against
his young opponent Vincent kaima dingley
run top right against the veneronium gee
I wonder what opening that is maybe an
Italian and a God on a limb here and yes
Italian but we've got some fascinating
positions yovi on the bottom of your
screen Geary and aragaisi in a very
tactical Queen's Gambit abdusatorov and
prognananda in an open urulopas which
always leads to some interesting
structures I'll pass it on to you where
shall we travel next
um I think it has to be bottom left to
Anish Gary against Arjun aragaisi
because there we probably have the
sharpest opening known to mankind
they've gone into the depths of the slav
I think or is it a Queen's Gambit
now you're absolutely right this is a
what's called a system
and the system is is actually a
series of lines in which black plays
this love and then captures on C4 and
follows up with this move B7 B5 as far
as I know this B5 move is what people
specifically refer to when they say
um and here we have a classic DC
D5 there we have it Bishop comes out to
B7 and A6 you'll be to prepare c65 and
typically if black plays C5 in a good
version then black has solved all of his
opening problems and so it makes perfect
sense uh to play E4 and D5 drive this
Pawn into the center and try to open up
the e-file before black has completed
his development and the last thing I'll
say here uh as we get to the live
position
do not take on T5 I do not even think
about it because if you just take twice
readily this doesn't lose on the spot
but why does this very very nasty move a
to A4 provoking weaknesses on the queen
side and if black plays B4 and after
Knight takes D5 Bishop takes D5 I mean
Bishop to G5 and even the engine moves
are very sensible Rook you want me to
just look how tense this is on the
e-file this looks incredibly
unappetizing for black and so instead of
this
uh our generic IC drives down onto C4
clearing a space on C5 potentially for
his Bishop after Queen C7 Queen E2 Yogi
we have a very theoretical a very rich
position as Arjun Ponders his next move
what do you make of this
yeah I'm I'm
actually from my knowledge black doesn't
I normally kick that Bishop so
in the game I mean I think it's much
more popular to move the queen to C7 but
okay we'll we will see and uh now hang
on it's a transposition actually I
misspoke and uh yep Queen moving to the
E2 Square I'm just again checking the
databases on it saying that it's the
second choice it's much more popular to
capture the pawn on esex
oh that's the old line yeah that is the
old line the queen E2 is modern take on
just keeping the position open and this
is such a rich position in terms of
piece play dynamism it's a very shaky
when it comes to King safety if you if
you worry about the role of your king or
the safety of a king just don't touch
this position if you don't touch this
opening if you want to play Black find
another line uh here I mean
I say this from experience because I
have been
um massacred actually there's no for
want of a better word I mean I've been
absolutely crushed on the black side of
this and I I it was a very unpleasant
experience so
but those of you who are brave those of
you who are bold will take solace in the
fact that you have fantastic porn
structure and long-term possibilities on
the queen side and look at the pieces I
mean look at those dark squares they're
amazing and if you control those if you
can create enough counter play along all
those open lines that are going to be
opened then okay black is going to be in
good shape
that was a fantastic explanation of the
pluses and minuses I mean the biggest
minus is just evident in the way that
White's pawns are arranged in the center
I mean there is just a bone in your
throat here with a pawns on e4 and T5
and opening up the e-file is completely
out of the question even if you win the
D5 Bond until until black manages to
Castle kingside and Tuck his King away
so from a logical perspective to me the
most sensible move is Bishop f8 to D6
prioritizing kingside Castle ASAP now
what else is Arjun contemplating here
you might be thinking about more
ambitious developing move Bishop C5
although that doesn't control the E5
Square quite as strictly as perhaps
black would like and this is already
worrying me on arjun's behalf because
Anish Gary has shown unbelievable
preparation throughout this tournament
he beat dukesh with just some absolute
magic in the opening and early middle
game we saw good preparation yesterday
with the black pieces and when you're
running it running into Anish Gary's
opening files and he's playing on the
white side of a I mean that sense
shivers down your spine so Arjun might
also be experiencing some of what the
world champion is thinking as he decides
what to recapture that night with where
okay do you go down the main line what
you know Anish has analyzed and his team
has analyzed or do you take a risk and
try to knock him out of his preparation
not an enviable task UV at all here for
Arjun as he continues to think about
where to develop his Dark Sword Bishop
yeah uh and I have to say though in this
type of position I mean it's so chaotic
it's that deep dark Forest I do feel
that you should tread on those
well-trodden paths I don't think now is
the time to get all creative and go
Rogue and put your Bishop on C5 I mean
the most logical move as you say is put
that Bishop on D6 and then I think you
should leave the creativity and the
exploration for a later stage in the
game
professionals yeah yeah yeah I agree I I
actually think the other candidate move
here which might be appealing to Arjun
is E6 E5 closing down the center and
then putting the bishop on D6 now the
bishop on D6 isn't going to be a great
piece but at least it's gonna blockade
the center Pawn the downside of playing
E5 is that you're also weakening this F5
square and white could actually respond
with the immediate Knight F3 to H4 not
only preparing a maneuver to F5 but also
Paving the way for F2 F4 blasting open
the king side doesn't look appealing to
me I'm going to predict Bishop D6 after
a little bit of a thing because Arjun
just kind of sitting back in his chair
there looking around seems a little bit
distant a little distracted but you just
never know what goes on in these players
Minds yeah I think he's trying to recall
his lines I mean perhaps he's decided
he's going to play Bishop out to D6 I
agree with you I'm not a big fan of
closing down the center
um
uh he's just recalling his lines is
trying to recall where he can vary he's
uh thinking about what he can do I mean
we have seen a Magnus in his game
against a niche I mean there it was a
dangerous or sad cautionary tale
actually for people trying to vary
because Magnus actually in that game
went rogue he was just saying oh you
know
anisha's taking some time he's a bit
hesitant maybe he doesn't know the
opening so well so I'm gonna take a
Gamble and play a line that isn't so
well known but has a dodgy reputation
and we saw what happened in that game so
Wyatt has a Dodger reputation yeah his
reputation did not improve on the basis
of that game no he fell on his own sword
so uh
it's a cautionary tale to take heat off
and uh okay so this one is brewing up
nicely shall we go back to the bird's
eye view and have a look at more games
deal
here we have our beautiful all board
view so we have kind of an interesting
division between some games that have
conventional openings and I would put uh
ding aronian into that category classic
Italian so kymer is a very theoretical
relopez as you see Wesley top left of
your screen driving that pawn up to A5
very double edged sword that pawn can be
a weakness but it also keeps the B4 Pawn
uh from getting supported by its
counterpart on A6 we just looked at Gary
aragaisy that is a game we are going to
be pinned to as it gets closer to the
middle game I'm also very interested in
notrex game against progdananda show we
have a look at that open re Lopez with
uh black getting the early Bishop pair
as far as I can see an interesting
choice
by notorbeck so yeah I'm going to rewind
this game a couple of moves here we had
an open Real Opus which involves like
taking on e4 this is not a Berlin in the
Berlin black does not play the immediate
A6 right plays D4 B5 and then D5 black
gives the pawn back this is all very
standard fare Bishop B3 though you'll be
as far as I know is a lot less common
than the main moves which are C3 and
Knight B to D2 and those moves can
transpose into each other
and a very interesting idea by another
break it just takes the Knight off the
board and says Bishop here what Bishop I
don't care about the bishop pair we need
two C3 and Rook F to E1
by abducator of what do we make of this
yeah uh it's unconventional things uh
it's quite in the long term it's quite
risky because you do feel that black
will be having the trumps you know after
all he can just drop the bishop back
somewhere and he has dark control of the
dark squares as you're pointing out and
uh he has the potential to gain space so
naughty Beck has to do something now I
mean he has to establish a positional
clamp with his Knights or he has to
initiate an attack I mean I'm a firm
believer if you give up the bishop pair
you've got to get something in return
and I'm suspecting that it might be
something to do with the light squares
I mean I I was just wondering if Bishop
can kind of drop Back the Night can get
to G3
um what can I say I'm a very direct
player I like to attack the king
yeah I do as well and I think you
mentioned light Square control there's
also some dark squares in the center
that can be controlled I think the best
way to understand white strategy is to
just assume the black plays you know an
empty move or pass move like rookated E8
I think Notre back might want to first
off they're broke from a it moves away
then A4 becomes a very nasty move and
perhaps that's part of the reason he
positioned his Queen on E2 if you go B4
sloppily you give up a very important
Pawn on A6 that's out of the question so
let's say after Rook fe1 black plays
Rook after d well here I think there's
another idea which is to drop the bishop
back to C2 aiming at the king side let's
say black plays H6 and now you establish
the dark Square control that you were
mentioning Knight B3 then you go Knight
fd4 and the reason you go with that
Knight well there's two reasons the
first is you have a major clamp over the
C5 Square the second is that you have
the possibility of driving your F Pawn
up the board so you've got potential on
both sides of the board and the eval bar
is laughing at me and saying you should
probably take onto E4 with a knight this
threatens the additional Knight C6
it forces the black Bishop back
and now I can go Queen D3 and threaten
Checkmate on H7 this could unravel
really really quickly for Black G6 E6
and you can already start thinking about
resigning so the way I would explain
this is that white has given up a pretty
big Advantage the bishop air the
position is pretty open so the bishop
pair is a big deal but White's got a lot
of factors in return Yogi that could
only really come out in a couple of
moves which make them hard to see at
first
yeah definitely and the variation you
show that is rather convincing I like it
and uh it's certainly an attack to be
very wary of I mean I I was also
thinking naturally if the bishop
dropping back to C2 but I love the idea
of Knight B3 and Knight D4 and that's a
difficult one to handle especially
because as you mentioned the night
coming to uh F to D4 will also release
the f-bourne and if those pawns also get
rolling it's another way to chip at the
black king
very
devious strategy a nice opening idea
from abdusa toroff
this smells of Leela Timmy this is the
kind of idea that Leela comes up with
stockfish is often very skeptical when
you give up the bishop pair like this
but having analyzed my fair share with
Lila chess Lila likes these well we will
likes these ideas as if it's a sentient
being I mean we're not far away from
that but often you get these ideas which
look kind of I don't want to say bad
that's too primitive of a word maybe not
appealing or you don't think they're
dangerous but then you start exploring
and you realize that there are these
hidden ideas that can transform your
position from seemingly innocuous to
incredibly dangerous and this is one of
those ideas I just love watching Notre
back play it seems that every game he
brings to the table creative ideas he
defends really really well and he's so
dangerous with the white pieces we saw
that in the Olympiad where he was part
of the the winning Uzbek team he came to
the table arm to the teeth and now once
again he sits on four out of five and
poses prognananda with a serious set of
early middle game challenges
I do like the idea as you mentioned and
interesting I hadn't really thought
about the the influence of the computers
actually like which players are using
What machines because of course we know
assesse is following Magnus Carlson
everyone at the top is using these super
engines the super computers
um just to Crunch out those variations
and I think someone kind of said it
yesterday is all about those small
margins finding those kind of ideas that
trick humans and this one I think is a
fantastically clever idea from Abdus a
lot of hidden danger a lot of poison
here
agree completely we can see that
outerbeck is super creative in the
opening but that's not the extent of his
prowess he is also a beast in the end
game as he displayed yesterday in his
sparkling win against the world champion
not a break up to satorov talks the
queen end game where he beat Magnus in
their first meeting with the black
pieces let's listen in to the Uzbek
phenom
um I think it's theoretically it's drawn
but uh in our game it was his King was
on uh on F2
uh while uh if
if White's Place King somewhere between
the H7 and G7 it's it's it's it's always
draw but he never had a chance to to get
this so yeah it's very tough end game uh
I think maybe objectively it's it might
be still still be a draw but it's
practically it's very almost impossible
um yeah it's one of the biggest wins of
course but not the best I would I would
say but yeah it's one of the biggest
a very measured motorbike of just tour
of after a win that would make me prance
around the playing Hall and jump on the
bed but just another day in the office
for the uh incredibly talented young
Uzbek player and he mentioned there that
the end game should be a draw but if the
world champion isn't able to hold an end
game then let's be real that end game is
essentially not holdable Yogi yeah no it
actually wasn't holdable and a few of
the grand Masters entered a dialogue on
Twitter where they were saying it's all
to do with the placing of the white king
the white King was in the back row and
this meant that it was going to be
automatically just lost and I agree with
you that um coming back to your earlier
point about how measured and how calm
and composed Nordic seemed because if
that had been me I I agree with you I
would have been doing cartwheels I mean
you would not have been able to wipe the
smile from my face because beating
Magnus and to me it's such a clean way I
mean that's unheard of and also let's
throw into beat he did it with the black
pieces too
he did indeed and perhaps when he came
back to his hotel room and the comfort
of his own room he let some of the
emotions out but you know when he's in
the playing Hall and he's in the thick
of things he stays professional he stays
calm and mature I really like that move
by Prague by the way Bishop C5 back to
B6 he's aware of notorbeck's Bishop C2
Knight B3 setup and preemptively moves
his dark skirt Bishop back to buy
himself a little bit more time to set
his pieces up in response to notorbeck's
idea H3 there by notorbeck so the
position kind of quieting down a little
bit as both players making cosmetic uh
and positional improvements to their
setup and we're going to keep an eye on
this game as it moves closer to the
middle game but you'll be I mean I
wouldn't say that white is better
objectively that much is clear but Notre
back aiming for a position in which he
is more familiar with the ideas in his
opponent we talked a lot about this
yesterday opening Fashions have shifted
it's a lot harder to find it's a lot
harder to refute a lie now like it like
it was in 2003 or Gary Kasparov just
knocked out certain lines of the
Sicilian and won games in 20 moves now
that ain't happening everybody has the
same engines so you've got to find
positions in which somehow you're more
comfortable with the ideas than your
opponent not necessarily objective
advantages because well those are
impossible to find now yeah it certainly
is and uh judging also by the speed of
nordeback's play he's very much in his
opening territory he has prepared this
he has put in the hard graft here so he
understands the the position and uh
pragnananda well he will be freestyling
now so so far I would say the opening
battle has gone lordy Beck's way
it has indeed and we will leave him to
his devices as we swing back to the
bird's eye view some of the games even
the ones that started with conventional
openings are kind of heating up and
getting unbalanced I'm talking about the
ding aronian game or the center has
exploded I'm talking about the sokaima
game where Vincent has a rook on B5 and
that Center has also exploded Shoei and
by the way Magnus has decided to take on
C6 with the queen so he does deviate
from the main theoretical path
fascinating Choice by the world champion
as well yovi my eyes are just bouncing
around the screen shall we go to the
Wesley game yes because uh you can
answer the question how on Earth did
that work get on B5 in out of the
opening
um
like how does this get so tactical so
quickly so he went Rook B8 which is a
pretty typical move but the idea isn't
usually to Rook on P5 it's usually to
you know support the B4 pawn and D4 by
Wesley which is not as common as playing
C3 first he says I don't care about the
prep move I want to smash through the
center immediately Vincent taking it
with his Knight we have a mass trade
first Wesley plays E5 driving the pawn
down then Vincent drops the Knight back
Wesley recaptures and here we go Rook B8
to B5 by the German Grandmaster he's got
his eyes on that A5 fun he says he drove
that pawn down I'm going to make you
regret it but man or his pieces passive
here
I mean they were clustered on the back
row apart from this rampant Rook there
on B5
um I mean artistically speaking this
isn't a league of its own
um
it really is here we are I mean I have
no words
um
it just seems like as you say it's very
much a one-track mind maybe he'll go C5
and go Brook takes porn
yeah I mean let's say white goes
actually Bishop C4 black can still go C5
yeah funnily enough Queen drops back you
take the pawn now the issue is that if
we continue calculating that's not the
end of the story congratulations you've
won my corner Pawn but this E5 Pawn
notice how it's really clamping down on
some of the on some of the key dark
squares in the center and on the king
side it makes this Knight just be
incredibly miserable on E8 and white
could play as simply as Knight to D2 get
the night out try to put it on e4 and if
black plays D6 and tries to forcibly
remove the pawn from the board and after
e takes D6 Bishop takes D6 the first
swoop of the day
does this work rookie 8 rookie8 Queen T6
yeah there is but uh you do have the
interception of Knight F1 F1 and yours
there's
not a force right Rick takes and I guess
Queenie seven wins
yeah too many threats too many threats
here
there's no pieces defending the black
king
so you always got to look after that man
that's a cool line and if that doesn't
work out for black then does Wesley want
to go down the path of just saying here
you want my A5 point take it I'm gonna
focus on developing and establishing my
Center dominance around that E5 Pawn
yeah
um yeah I mean Wesley is very much in
clamping mode and uh one rule of thumb
that I have is when that pawners are
when the white Pawn is on E5 then that
is the red flag that you should attack
on the king side
and uh here you know it has a nice
clamping effect but I do also see the
Merit in just developing your pieces and
if uh Vincent tries to break that bind
then shifting all the pieces in to
attack the king and if I'm a Vincent I
would not be happy with the placing of
my pieces I mean the first thing that I
would do is yes I would go C5
but not necessarily to capture that pawn
because after all that pawn is a little
bit irrelevant I would be probably
putting my knight on C7 and E6 and just
located in the E5 Pawn you know Knights
are the perfect locators
and then just to reacting to whatever
comes my way
agreed and we will see how I mean for
Wesley it's not even a choice of whether
he wants to sack A5 you really can't
stop black from playing C5 so he's got
that one tempo and the question really
is well where how does he want to set up
his bishop and his Knight does he want
to bring the Knight out first does he
want to bring the bishop out first and
make it even harder for black to play D6
later on a lot of positional and
tactical choices here to make for the
American Grand Master who you mentioned
Yogi is is fuming at his five draw start
now Wesley is a very solid player but
the misconception is that these top
players are always okay withdraws no
they are not especially with the white
pieces they are trying to win it's just
that Wesley has a very solid style that
sometimes leads to consecutive draws but
when he comes to a tournament like Todd
of Steel he wants to bring his a game as
Vichy pointed out this is the tournament
in which the players are most passionate
about showing good form
yeah absolutely you know this is one of
the most important tournaments in the
calendar it's like a grand slam you want
to win it you want to pick up those
Prestige points and uh yeah Wesley of
course will have come into this one with
ambitions and he has a very ambitious
position I mean
I like it I like this Pawn on E5 I like
the fact that Wesley can just has
developed his pieces I mean move the
Knight towards the center and he has
lots of attacking potential as you
mentioned
he does indeed we see him there on
camera hand over forehead pondering his
next move Vincent has got up from the
chair so doesn't necessarily mean he's
happy with the position sometimes it
actually means you're so nervous about
your position that you don't want
anything to do with it so I propose we
leave Wesley to his devices if it's
critical middle game position and take
another look at our bird's eye view Eric
icy has decided to Castle Queen side and
each Gary continues to Blitz out his
responses of that game continues to heat
up and get crazier we've got an
interesting Sicilian report by Sudlow
and the dingaronian game Yobe really has
taken a path I did not expect okay shall
we uh check in on these old rivals and
Old Friends
let's do it ding against Lavon aronian
who sits pretty on plus one after
yesterday's Victory uh over Vincent
kymer so what do we make of this
position and I guess the first question
is how did we get here this was a
regular Italian and Lavon he did not
waste any time 97 didn't goes D4 very
typical right the moment the Knight
leaves C6 you often want to go D4 but
the standard response is ed484 and D5
forcing an isolated Queen Pawn structure
now the last thing I'll say and I'll
pass it back to UOB normally when you
talk about iqp structures it's all about
who controls the square in front of the
pawn so you may wonder why Lavon didn't
play in ite 65. well the problem is that
white plays Bishop G5 and even though
you seem to control the D5 square
there's a lot of other problems in
Black's position white goes Knight C3
very quickly this pin is dangerous and
white is already threatening to take on
D5 and Force black to recapture with the
pawn and so for this reason Lavon starts
with H6 and ding just continues to
harass him on both sides of the board A4
threatening to trap the bishop and
eliciting a dilemma does Lavon want to
play A6 or does he want to play the
slightly more weakening but potentially
safer move A5
yeah it is a dilemma actually
um my personal inclination is actually
just to move the pawn one square forward
just because I I do like good Pawn
structure and he doesn't there was a
third option that we hadn't considered
and has to Simply to block that pawn
with the bishop tacking The Rook at the
same time now
it wasn't instinctive primarily because
I feel that the bishop is not that great
there on A5 and also it's an open
position you don't want to lose time
every move has to come with purpose and
the natural move for me has just simply
developed the night
developed the night and uh I mean but
here we're in the concrete territory
because after Knight takes D5 I have to
have an answer
and uh yeah because C3 hangs yeah and so
here again I would be inclined to pile
on the pressure yep you called it that
was right there on my mind and
how to continue
because white actually has to use the
mobility of their pieces has to use that
freedom to start targeting black and
putting them under pressure and it
sounds very vague and it is very vague
because I'm not actually giving you this
is something that I I try to get all my
students to think about I try to get
them to think specifically on certain
points because a lot of the time I go
what do you do and they go attack and
I'll go very well well done but your
pieces are dumb and your pieces need
concrete instruction
but you're right attack at this point
and I mean what you're saying Bears out
in iqp structures because you've got
this big weakness and this weakness is
going to plague you uh particularly if
you start trading a lot of the other
pieces you what you don't want to do is
trade the queens and trade the Rooks and
just be left with nothing but this
weakness and so as you're saying you
need to compensate for it by generating
maximum peace activity so in a situation
like this I'm looking at moves like 95
but on the pressure on F7 try to get
this Knight to remain locked on D5 but I
think black's position here is very
solid it can also be a little bothersome
to play like you can't bring the bishop
out because you blunder B7 if you say oh
well let me play rugby eight first and
you blunder into another tactic Knight
takes D6 so you know looks can be
deceiving and these active pieces that
white has can make White's position a
lot easier to play from a practical
standpoint so Bishop A5 you'll be it's
an interesting creative it's a very
aronian-esque move but he has to be very
disciplined about May making sure that
he keeps control over the D5 square and
you know doesn't accidentally blunder
into a tactic or allow dang species to
get too active yeah absolutely uh
whenever you play an IQ position whether
you're attacking or whether you're
defending you are burning your time in
the opening that is the most critical
stage when it comes to the middle games
again you must be looking for the
aggressive options for both sides of the
board and an end game if you still have
your iqp well you've got to start
controlling the line that's your only
compensation
um here yeah it's a very fascinating
position I did not expect Bishop A4 I
mean is there any other way that white
can put pressure after I mean Knight C3
is the move that's kind of begging to be
played
there is Bishop D2 and that again does
actually comply with the idea that if
your opponent has wasted a lot of time
with one one piece in particular you
should trade it off because then that
time that they've used in the past has
been wasted now obviously
these rules are not hard on Fast rules
and you need to judge every position
independently but I mean yeah let's try
this bishop D2
yeah Bishop D2 I take it and after Queen
takes D2 I take D5 I actually don't like
shift D2 all that much uh because well
it complies with one principle it
violates another and the other principle
concerns proper play when you have the
isolated Queen Pawn you typically want
to avoid minor peace trades and it seems
to me that the dark squared Bishop does
hold a lot of potential I mean I know
this is way in the future but you can
think about Saxon H6 they're not that
uncommon in iqp positions so you know if
if white is a choice I think keeping
minor pieces on the board uh is is the
better bet so if I had to make a
prediction here I think ding's gonna go
Knight C3 but you know maybe there's
something that I'm not fully seeing
after Bishop D2 it does give white a
chance to accelerate the development of
his pieces so there are some pluses to
that move for sure and the only other
move I wanted to ask you about because
it's so weird and wonderful and we have
seen a very weird and wonderful move is
what happens if he just goes completely
crazy puts the Rook on E5 and goes oh
yeah that's how I'm getting my pressure
now we're speaking my language and
actually that's a very serious candidate
if you think about it rookie five x-rays
that darn Bishop which has landed on A5
it's not really in ding's style and
maybe rookie 5 can be met with Knight to
G6 just saying get off me get out of
there but you could leave The Rook on E5
just sack The Exchange and then get you
know these two impressive pawns on D5 so
there's a lot to think about here for
tingly run this is a big decision that's
really going to dictate the course of
this early middle game yeah no I have to
I love it
a warning you know I only suggested
rookie five because of the game between
Vincent climber and Wesley so
um okay
taking inspiration from one board and
applying it to another it's like those
yeah it's like when people repeat the
same opening on Two on Two neighboring
boards and then you have to physically
move them away from each other that
happened once I think in a tournament in
Gibraltar many years ago the famous
story I was there I was there it
happened uh in the the grand Swiss in
the Isle of Man and I remember because I
was it was my ambition to get off the
bottom row and I I managed it once and
on that one time I managed to get off
the bottom row someone came in these two
grand Masters came and started playing
their game uh and this other in this
other room and they just came after like
one hour and we were like what is
happening and then it kind of transpired
that that they were two boards next to
each other and they were playing the
exact same game
it's it's just so unlikely when you
think about it totally totally and uh
yeah and it's also a neat trick a neat
mind trick you can do to beat people in
a symbol you just play them off against
each other or goes around comes around
yeah I always know that reference yeah
and I know who Darren Brown is yeah um
fantastic mind magician he took on some
Chess Masters Grand Masters and uh yeah
he he managed to bury them
well you uh are responsible for the
rabbit hole I'm gonna go on this evening
after we finish commentating but perhaps
I'm gonna start this Rabbit Hole during
our first break as we take one more look
here at the bird's eye view and the
Beautiful playing Hall here at Tata
steel the 85th edition of this historic
event you can see the open section
players dutifully thinking over
complicated positions we have another
set of fascinating games in round six do
not go anywhere because we will be back
with more coverage of Tata steel chess
on the other side of this short break
do you wish playing a chess game with a
friend was as easy as sending them a
text well good news now it is but
chess.com's new iMessage app you can
start and play a game directly in
iMessage your friend doesn't even need a
chest.com account it's just tap and play
head over to go.just.com iMessage or use
the command iMessage in chat to learn
more
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
we are back at the 85th edition of the
Tata steel chess tournament this is
round six happy Friday everybody we hope
you're enjoying this first hour of
coverage as the games get underway and
most of them have already exited the
opening stage and entered some
fascinating middle games as we have a
look at that beautiful playing Hall in
the small seaside village of Wake On Zay
and here we have the bird's eye view all
of the games as they currently sit and
you'll be wherever your eyes turn there
are just some rich fascinating tactical
and positional battles I'm thinking it
might be a good idea for us to summarize
quickly each position just so
everybody's on the same page and perhaps
then we could delve into the craziness
which is going on uh on the bottom left
between Geary and Eric Isley so Wesley
against kymer we have upon Sacrifice by
Wesley in return for some very powerful
compensation revolving around that E5
Pawn which really clamps down Black's
position to the right of that we've got
digging against Iranian we kind of
called it Knight C3 Knight takes D5 a
very rich iqp structure I think we're
gonna leave Gary aragaisi to the side
and I'll let you take notorbeck's game
against uh prognano which is also
getting pretty heated yeah that is
certainly getting heated and it's really
going to be a battle of uh Styles here
because nordeback is very much
positionally playing the game he has
some aggressive attentions on the queen
slide and also the king side and it's
going to come down to the Stark Square
controls under there we see him just
prod the queen side a little bit and I
do like his position and then we have a
Jordan van Forest against Magnus Carlson
and Magnus did actually capture that
Knight all the way back in the opening
with a queen and uh here it kind of
still feels that they're very much in
the openings the Kings haven't been
Castle just yet and the big question for
Magnus is where is he going to put his
King how is he going to develop his King
side pieces
it's not an ambival task actually if it
feels slightly unpleasant for the world
champion at this current point in time
and then we have Richard report against
para maxulu what do you think about this
one white of course has a very beautiful
Knight sitting there slap bang in the
middle of the board
I kind of like it I think white has a
slight Advantage just based on that
piece
yeah he does and I'm particularly
passionate about that game because this
is a line I play with white and I had a
very similar position uh two tournaments
ago so we'll definitely uh take a visit
to that game in in due course uh and of
course we will also visit the rightmost
game karawana gukesh which is also
heating up we've got the pawn box in the
center as who cash pushes C5 he has
yielded the bishop pair in what looks to
be some sort of nimso Indian kind of
structure he's deployed his light
squared Bishop uh to what I call the
high perfume keto Square on A6 where it
stares at its counterpart on F1 so a
very rich position uh as we see Fabiana
car one they're they're deep in
concentration uh on the camera but
really the the game that is stealing the
show for me right now of course magnus's
game is is very rich and we will update
you on the world champion situation but
first let's take a look at what is going
on between Anish Gary and Arjun aragaisy
we remind you that this was a that
slav the sharpest variation of the slav
anishagiri displaying some of his
typical sharp opening preparation he
forces what Black's King to seek shelter
on the queen side but I mean talk about
shelter there might be no shelter left
after Anish Gary's last move which
threatens to blast open the queen Side
open the sea file and Black's King could
get victimized real fast
yeah that this is a very dangerous
position very critical for the young
Indian player because primarily has a
big choice he's been given the
opportunity to step forward oh yeah
let's let's see how things happened and
there we can see that Eric Garcia
Carlson is King Rick has been chased and
of course B3 breaking open the position
and the big thing is whether he can
actually get away with pushing that c
Pawn one square forward because ideally
that's what you like to do it's not what
your pieces are it's what they do and
that guy is two squares away from home
and if that can be supported by another
pawn and I mean what is White's rook in
comparison I mean there's nothing and uh
I I just can he get away with it because
you know you are thinking your moves
like like you've pointed out A4
I'm a terrified yeah
I mean but then again maybe I would be
terrified here I would be totally
terrified yeah I would be shaking in my
boots but if somehow you can survive
this is it possible I mean can the
bishop
I mean step back or the queen can come
slide across to B7 try to consolidate
everything
or is that a more tactical kind of
solutions to the problem I mean this is
such a sharp position
so I'll point out two things first I
mean B4 is not out of the question but
this is more of a desperate measure
because giving up Asics with check yeah
you're not going to get checkmated here
uh with black on the next move but the
issue is that as nice as the C3 Pawn
looks from a cosmetic standpoint it's so
well blockaded I mean I just cannot
Envision a reality where this Pawn
becomes an actual existential threat to
white I mean even if the bishop wasn't
on C2 there's just too many pieces on
the board but there's a couple other
problems that black is dealing with if
you don't play before in this position
if you play a move like B7 White's going
to jump at the opportunity to open that
a file not only that the B5 Pawn is weak
you could play a move like Knight C4 I
mean I don't like this phrase I think
it's overused in commentary but the
position really plays itself at this
point you just bring pieces to the queen
side and with Black's King side not yet
developed you're gonna have to burn
another move to bring your dark squid
Bishop out this is exactly how you lose
in five moves if you're Argent so I
actually don't think he can get away
with C3 I think you should keep his
spawn on C4 but that means he gives
white an opportunity to either ruin
Black's Pawn structure uh and and you
know soften the pawns up or open the C
file which might be even worse given how
easy it is for white to bring a rook to
C1 but if I had to predict to move I
would be thinking in the direction of
Bishop to A3 uh or maybe bishop to C5 to
put a little bit more distance between
whites Rooks and Black's King but let me
make one thing very very clear this is
once again phenomenal opening
preparation by Gary who sits at 90
minutes on his clock he's only spent 10
minutes and I mean Arjun is clearly out
of his prep he's out of his comfort zone
and this is a huge opportunity for Anish
to win again I mean I don't think it's
premature you know to talk about white
winning because black could make one
more inaccuracy and this game could be
over yeah absolutely I mean I hear from
black would be entirely thinking in a
defensive point of view I would be
thinking what on Earth is white going to
be doing next and you kind of called it
A4 is coming it's on the horizon and I
love your move of putting the bishop on
A3 stop that one as long as you have a
as an answer porn takes porn Bishop
takes porn closing down the lines black
is relatively safe for the time being
now of course you have to judge this and
I'm move by move basis you can't be
thinking about the position in the long
time you can't be dreaming about the
future you've got to be dealing with
what is in front of you right now
um
I also have to say
I didn't mind giving up the porn with C3
and B4
I mean that looks pretty darn good
doesn't it in comparison yeah
you know I just opening up lines I mean
this is the kind of this is what you
want to do when you
you're attacking you want to open up
your lines so the pieces can infiltrate
and yeah anything to stop that so
I I think for for me it would be either
Bishop A3 or the line where you
sacrifice a pawn where you actually do
close down and go C3 and B4 and just say
yep you've won a pawn but I've
Consolidated the position and now I can
concentrate on developing my pieces
because
I mean we kind of spoke about this
yesterday about how chess is
fundamentally unfair that when white hat
or when one side has a bad piece or
usually Pawn you can't just get rid of
it you can't go thank you very much
you've done your job I don't like you
anymore get off the board
um I mean and that's what white would
kind of want to do with the a pawn like
well I
that piece doesn't belong here anymore
so yeah
this is a very as you put it unenviable
situation for the Indian Grand Master
and Anish giri like he's taking it
personally because Eric icy does have a
winning streak in in Rapid against Anish
gear even any winning streak in any time
control against the niche is uh is is
something to hang your hat on but when
we talk about Anish giri I I always feel
like the storyline that is falsely uh
bandied about and this hasn't been true
for for many years now of course Anish
has this reputation he cannot seem to
shake as the kind of draw Master at the
top now this has nothing to do with
statistical reality and it also has
nothing to do with his actual play style
I mean people might not realize that a
niche in his youth was a one E4 player
he played the Sicilian with black
growing upanisha was a very tactical
player now he did modify his style when
he entered super Grand Master land many
years ago and then he modified his style
again after that famous candidates
tournament where he earned the
reputation and made all 11 draws or
whatever he changed his openings he
displayed sharper opening preparation
you look at positions that he has now
and they're not the exception they are
the norm and ishqiri is a new man and I
think it's time to move on from that
reputation of course the most famous
stat is that he's his five-time
runner-up in vikon say you can't make
that stuff up can you yeah I agree with
you I mean it's very very unfortunate
that this one tournament has saddled him
with this idea that he's a drawer master
that he just simply plays the most solid
positions known to mankind I mean even
in that tournament which is commonly
referenced I mean those drawers were
fighting chess and so it's super unfair
and hello we have a move from aragaisi
and wasn't the bishop coming to A3 and
it wasn't the pawn moving forward
locking down the queen side instead the
bishop comes to C5
and the first thing that I would be
thinking of is hello let's open some
lines let me capture that pawn on C4 and
after Bishop takes block that attack and
I feel that Black's position is starting
to wobble
yeah it definitely is and
our generic icy I mean I don't want to
talk about body language with origin
it's impossible to talk about body
language he doesn't get too high of the
highest doesn't get too low at all he
looks the same no matter what's going on
on the board but I think you're
absolutely right B take C4 here looks
delicious and after Bishop C4 you play
Bishop to D3 you shake some of the
pieces off the C file and then you put a
rook on C1 and uh I'll put these moves
on the analysis board unless I'm missing
something so takes takes here now maybe
black should drop back to D5 but that
doesn't change the fact that I can put
the Rook on two on and there's a lot of
good stuff sitting there on the C file
and quaking in their boots but if you
take and if you take I could not this is
the pawn Ikea released about in the
history of Pawns I please take what you
want to take I'll take back on E5 and I
think where kc1 works even here with the
beautiful idea that if black takes the
bishop Queen D6
and it's all over
well evobar disagrees but I mean I think
it's all over I think that's a cool
ignore what the engine is exactly thank
you for saying that maybe Queen D4 is
better but I think people get the point
this is I mean there's like a couple
moves separating Anish giri from getting
to Black's King I'm really curious what
Arjun has in mind as in store against
this simple path
yeah I'm uh I don't know I I can't
figure it out because I mean we talked
about the principles earlier on and uh
it's always the kind of Maxim that you
lock the position down and you don't
play with an exposed Kings and look who
are coming towards the black king it's
the big guys it's the queen it's the
rook
and there we go one takes Pawn on the
board and I have to say in this
tournament it just seems that a niche
has been extremely clever with his
opening choices I mean it's it's like he
sends the opponent's weaknesses and he's
just play okay there we see uh
aragaisy's answer is actually Pawn takes
porn
and it's forced yeah absolutely
what but still it's not a movie it's a
move you play with a heavy heart I mean
rook ac1 and Bishop E4 and black is
really teetering on the brink here now I
don't want to overstate the case I think
if black puts the Knight on B6 right
let's not pretend that Arjun doesn't
have any trumps in his position he does
he has active pieces he's got the open f
file so Anish the last thing he wants to
do right now is rest on his Laurels and
play Slowly he has to keep his foot on
the gas pedal and he has to maintain
Precision but he's got the 20 minute
time advantage to boot he's got clearly
an objectively better position so you
could not have asked for a better
scenario out of the opening or anishkiri
and for a more challenging task for the
winner of last year's Tata steel
Challengers who is obviously facing a
challenge of a completely different kind
this year I mean what an experience this
is for for Arjun eragisi who it seems
hasn't lost a game in years but he's
already pretty close to that first loss
in this game yeah and he is riding on
the Airship but I do agree with you we
shouldn't get carried away and just kind
of judge everything by the evaluation
bar because as you pointed out black
doesn't have an awful lot of Defenders
around his king and you know an
inaccurate move by Anish and suddenly
the position can turn and something that
a niche will be thinking about is how he
can keep the pieces on the board he does
not want to go into an end game and uh
well whilst this game is brewing nicely
shall we check the bird's eye view and
have a look at the other games
we absolutely shall we will keep a close
eye on Geary aragaisy Geary the
five-time runner up to Tata steel has
positioned himself very very handsomely
through the first five rounds as he sits
in second place and there we have it the
bird's eye view we've got the world
champions game which uh might go into a
queenless middle game I wouldn't even
call that an end game so definitely a
lot to explore there my proposal is that
we take a brief look at that potential
end game and then perhaps take a look at
caruana gukesh for the first time how
does that how does that plan sound that
sounds like a great idea let's do it
and so we kind of rewind a little bit to
see how we got here yes so we last uh
looked at the game Carlson playing the
team on of and the very rare capture on
C6
then black responds after a prolonged
think with Queen takes C6 issuing the
tempting BC trying to get out of
Jordan's preparation now the queen on C6
is a very vulnerable piece it's
pressuring E4 but when a bishop lands on
F3 it x-rays the queen and the rook and
that is precisely what happened Jordan
develops Magnus with a typical Sicilian
move B5 and there we have it Bishop to
F3 creating the massive threat of E5
forcing black to respond which he does
with Bishop B7 Jordan centralizing his
own Queen and Magnus with a move you
don't see every day in the Sicilian how
often do you say queen C6 to D6 on move
10.
yeah and uh I like his idea because I
did feel that the world champion was
under some kind of pressure because I
kind of said that in the quick Roundup
was it wasn't that easy for black to
develop his King side pieces you know
the Knight was gonna get kicked around
dark Square Bishop couldn't develop
itself because of the queen eyeing up G7
so when you're under some pressure
you're feeling the heat it's often a
good idea to trade queens and of course
in the Sicilian the end game is usually
favorable for black because they can use
the half open Line better than white
news that half open d-line so it's a
battle between c and d and Magnus of
course we've seen him he's just
magnificent in the end game
he most certainly is and I I like his
General approach of steering the game
into the type of position he is most
comfortable with there's nothing wrong
with that especially when you're
struggling and Magnus is most definitely
struggling he's on two out of five he's
on minus one now it would be a gross uh
under sort of it would be it would be a
gross exaggeration to say that oh they
trade the Queens therefore this is a
draw this is could not be further from
the truth this end game is actually
going to be very rich so I can sense
some of the groans in the chat on the
Queens are often we're not going to get
a tactical Sicilian unless white plays
Knight T5 which is somehow I don't think
Jordan is going to play I think the big
question for Jordan is on what terms
does he want to trade Queens I don't
think you want to take D6 because that
helps black develop his bishop and then
perhaps centralize it on E5 I think the
big choice is between castle and queen
side trading on White's own terms and
then centralizing his own bishop or
there's the interesting move Queen D4 to
D3 basically saying I'll allow the queen
trade but you're gonna have to enable me
to shift one of my pawns away from the C
file taking some of the sting away from
Rook C8 and toward the center somewhat
blunting the influence of Black's light
squared Bishop I think Queen D3 is a
very serious candidate move Jordan
should consider it carefully
yeah uh I agree
um I must admit I didn't see Queen D3 I
was just thinking in terms of castling I
really like the idea of just activating
the rook and uh getting the bishop to
this long diagonal and again asking
black how are you going to develop your
own dark Square Bishop
um Which choice would you prefer
um
I don't know 23 Is Creative but
I feel like Jordan's gonna Castle it's
just such a tempting move it's so
natural and it's really hard to resist
moves like that
yeah and and
there's nothing wrong with it either
there's absolutely nothing
uh I mean other options could be
but again you know you're playing Magnus
so you don't really want to be play
making moves that compromise your own
Pawn structure another move that kind of
crossed my mind was to go E5 just to
kind of clamp down get some space but
yeah this kind of allows the kind of
position where Magnus will plonk a
knight on F5 and then just simply grind
away use that half open C line for his
Rooks and just connect his pieces
towards a harmonious point so yeah not
advisable
yeah what's worse than playing Magnus in
an end game playing Magnuson and end
game with that pawn structure
[Laughter]
don't go there
if you want to draw against Magnus you
should probably keep the pawn structure
symmetrical and simple that's a very
safe way to play against anyone higher
rated than you
um boring but good
um yeah probably keep the Queens on the
board too
yes absolutely that's think so I mean
you kind of have to do the old old
advice you know I just think
complications are the way forward where
both of you are taking risks but of
course this is very very difficult to
get against someone stronger
and yeah yeah
so again a nice strategical battle uh
shaping up in the game between Jordan
and Magnus
indeed and Jordan will continue trying
to decide on what terms he wants to
trade Queens we have a really
interesting graphic to share with you on
Carlson's historic performances in like
on Zain through his first five games
this of course is round six and you can
see 2023 it stands out but he's had his
share of mediocre performances 2020 he
finished second he won three games in
the second half of the tournament but
2018-2019 Carlson isn't really known for
his spectacular starts in tada's deal
but you can see plus one plus one for
him to be minus one well that is totally
unheard of and the the rightmost column
is losses the middle column is draws the
leftmost column corresponds to the win
and then the craziest that of all
Carlson has not lost two in a row in
classical since 2015 I mean you can just
keep repeating that it doesn't add up
[Laughter]
yeah that's unheard of right it was
eight years ago the last time that
Magnus lost two classical games in a row
ah I mean I I think I can mention
last year November when I lost two games
in a row
um but
I mean this is crazy and I think someone
else came up with a stat I saw on
Twitter that in 2019 Magnus did not lose
a single game
yes this year has been a tough start for
him he's lost two games I mean but it's
just ridiculous if you think about it I
mean that we're talking like this I mean
if someone loses two games big deal but
because it's Magnus and because the
stats are so impressive and that's why
we're kind of
holding him to this high standard but it
is not really human when you think about
it I mean we should allow these top
players just to make mistakes lose some
games and without panicking and just
catastrophize
catastrophize I'm gonna okay you get
what I'm saying that's actually a
fantastic word and I would use that
exact word because chess fans just have
this way of having first of all recency
effect you know a player is a bad
tournament he's on a permanent Decline
and Magnus is never going to win a
tournament ever again uh you know that's
it the gods have spoken and he might as
well retire to save face and all of this
on the basis of like one game uh but
what's even crazier I was gonna say
about the than the 2015 statistic is
that the last time Carlson has lost two
games in out of steel before and that
has happened once it happened in 2007 a
year in which Carlson came dead last in
tata steel so right now I'm telling you
he's probably remembering that year it
was not a good year for Magnus and if
just think about how long Magnus has
dominated the World Elite 2007 I think
was probably the last time Magnus has
come last in any tournament that he's
ever played so he's lost two in a row
before and Todd of Steal but that was
way way back that was the year the
iPhone came out
I was gonna say to me 2007 doesn't sound
that long ago but we do have to remember
that you know Magnus is like 17 in 2007
so I'm sure he's not thinking about what
he did as a kid
um I think he's focusing on the here and
now and you know he has this great habit
and this great tendency just simply to
you know just focus on the job in hand
when he sits there in front of the board
he is just thinking about the chess
that's it
he is indeed and Jordan van Forrest took
some time to think about how he wanted
to trade queens and decided to do it
directly I don't like that decision I
think this helps black get the bishop
into the center and Magnus he just seems
a little bit surprised there but Bishop
E5 followed by D6 he's gotten exactly
the kind of position he's wanted a rich
playable end game with some imbalances
and the opportunity to outplay his
opponent so if you're Jordan van Forest
buckle up because you're gonna have to
show some filigree accuracy if you want
to prevent the world champion from
moving back to 50 all right let's get
back to the bird's eye view this end
game is going to keep unfolding and we
will bring you updates as they come but
Ivanka just another Super Rich round
we've got a nishkiri launching a furious
attack against Arjun eragisi's Queen
side King we've got I'm just a tour of
prognananda that's seriously heating up
with uh Prague advancing his Pawn to D4
karwana gukesh another game we haven't
looked that yet Super Rich positional
struggle what catches yourself shall we
uh pop in and carry on a good cash
because after all this is the big
Revenge match because of course Fabiana
caruana lost to gcash in the Olympiad
last year I was an incredible moment
actually that uh I think they beat India
beat America
yeah Gucci had a pretty bad performance
though he only started eight out of
eight
I mean really pathetic honestly you
shouldn't be invited back to the team
India
now he's in trouble here though he's in
trouble here
yeah he definitely looks like he's in
trouble because I mean just take a look
at the queen and the bishop lined up
together on that long diagonal I mean
that would be sending shivers down my
spine and of course let's not forget the
white Rook eyeing down the black queen I
mean but if I work a cash you know I'd
always feel that when you're defending
you should be thinking positively you
can't be just going down this
mire of darkness and just thinking why
am I playing like this you need to think
positively and there is one positive
aspect and that's why it's king stuff
still stuck in the middle
they yeah it's not much but it's
something
it's it's something other than even that
can evaporate if white plays Bishop
between castles now I'm curious how this
happened because when I looked at this
position in kind of a superficial manner
I thought well this is a complicated you
know equal struggle but the more I look
at it the more miserable it appears
let's do a quick postmortem this was a
rogozin which of course remains one of
the most popular openings at the highest
level Queen A4 check it doesn't win the
bishop the point of the move is to force
Black's Knight onto C6 making it more
difficult for black to contest the
center this is a very well-known line of
the rugosen gukesh moves his Knight back
to E7 uh to make it possible to play C5
and the big decision comes after Bishop
D2 B6 karawana forces to catch to make a
decision he decides to give up the
bishop pair which is not unheard of in
the regosan it's actually very common
the bishop comes out to A6 looks pretty
okay are on a defense and I think the
mistake the big mistake was I think
Lucas just prematurely played C5 he's
opening up the center with the idea of
exploiting White's King but I think it's
had the opposite effect it's opened up
White's Bishop it's allowed Fabi to set
up this battery against the Knight The
Rook is vulnerable the dark squares are
weak and I think White's King is safer
than it appears I don't think black has
the Firepower to actually produce
problems here
yeah and the more I look at it the more
I see problems like for instance if you
do try to defend the Night by uh perhaps
improving the worst place peace like the
Knight on E7 if you move that out of the
way then of course you fall vulnerable
super B4 and uh one thing I kind of
wanted to say about yeah that would be a
nasty uh skewer pin I don't know which
one it is
um but it's something and it's
unpleasant and I wanted to say something
about um
um gagash's uh ragozen this is something
that he plays all the time
and he's very faithful to that I mean we
talked about you know in the openings
you know whether if you're surprised by
something should you stick to what you
know stick to something you've studied
or do you just shift and here
he has stuck to a faithful opening but
it does mean that Fabi is in some prep
and and your cash is in some serious
difficulties is Fabi there sitting back
down I I don't see an alternative to
Knight F6 to E8 if we look concretely
well fabi's threatening to take twice on
F6 and that will be an actual
catastrophe but after 98 I mean Fabi has
such a vast array of options he can play
E4 uh to accentuate the pressure on the
D5 you can play B4 Bishop B he could
just develop his light squared Bishop
for goodness's sake and the worst thing
about positions like these is that
sometimes you're worse in the short term
but you've got some long-term advantages
if you can solve these short-term
problems okay then you've got things
that you can exploit later down the line
the problem here is that white both has
a very strong initiative there are
concrete threats but white is also
positionally better he's got the bishop
air and the dark Square control so even
if gukesh gets out of the immediate
danger he's still going to be suffering
for the foreseeable future due to
White's better placed pieces and once
again that Bishop pair so he has dug in
himself into a serious whole Yogi 14
moves in and Fabi has to start winning
some games this is a big opportunity
that he will not want to let slip no
definitely not I mean the position
feels like you can't really be going
back to E8 with a knight it just feels
too passive and I was kind of wondering
whether black should try to accelerate
the play and in which case I was
thinking about moves such as B5 you know
give up the pawn on F6 and try to get
some compensation
on the queen side I mean I know B5 looks
horrible especially because you allow
white a protective passport but I was
just trying to reduce the tension in the
center
yeah I think the issue might be the move
like B4 Bishop B4 forcing The Rook away
right that's what I that's what I was
wondering about I was wondering also
whether
but uh
okay but maybe I'm panicking so if we
were to kind of play it calm and Play
the knights into E8 which is an ugly
move it's not pretty but I have to say
we have seen it a remarkable amount of
times we saw it twice yesterday White
Knight came to E1 Magnus did there and
uh Jordan van Forest also did it in
yesterday's game against param and both
people lost so maybe this is not a great
advert for putting the Knight on the
eighth but sometimes needs must right so
I mean
it looks horrible but I mean how bad is
it in reality
well I think Eva bar has it right I I
don't usually like to quote the
evaluation but this is like a round of
like a plus 1.5 position and that plus
two would be winning so this is we're
right on the threshold of white being
clearly better and white being winning I
would say that white is a big Advantage
here but as gukesh now drops below an
hour on the clock he's obviously trying
he sees 98 he knows that that move is in
his pocket and he knows it doesn't lose
immediately but you have to put aside
your pride when you make a move like
that and and sometimes that's just what
you have to do you have to say yes I
really messed up the opening I messed up
an opening I'm supposed to know but
there's no shame in messing up an
opening against Fabiano caruana and what
you don't want to do if you're gukesh is
just go completely crazy carwana has way
too much time and way too much
experience so I am expecting 98 I think
kukesh is gonna hunker down and mount a
long and arduous defense because he has
a long and arduous task ahead of him I
see Ponders his next move you'll be
tough stuff tough sledding so far this
tournament or the young Indian Prodigy
yeah it's been a it's a hard battle
and of course there are no easy games in
this tournament these are the world's
finest players battling amongst each
other so shall we take out check out the
bird's eye view
and uh see where the excitement is
happening elsewhere
um
it is I mean everyone is just coming to
the games fit for a fight and uh can we
have a look at the games between Richard
Rapport and Parham because I don't think
we've checked in on them too much we
have not checked into it yet there's
also a lot of liquidation going on
in the notorbeck game so we'll get that
to you next but definitely we should
take a look at the report game I have a
vested interest in this game because I
play this line with white this started
out I'm going to rewind and show this
game from the start we're only 12 moves
in this was a sicilian that seemed to go
off the rails pretty quickly white plays
D4 CD and queen takes D4 I know this as
the check over variation after Vitale
check over a Soviet I am maybe it's
called differently and more
knowledgeable circles like responds with
the Knight F6 this is kind of a new move
previously Knight C6 was pretty
automatic but it transpired that E5
which was considered the old reputation
a reputation lost its refutation on
account of a knight C6 and so white
plays this much more positionally Knight
C3 dropped the queen back to D3 and now
modern chess move the same piece twice
in the opening and try to establish a
clamp in the center and the philosophy
behind this line consists of two pillars
the first is that if you take the Knight
on D5 White establishes this incredibly
nasty Pawn that just clamps down and
takes the fun out of Black's Center play
the second is that the Knight on C3 is
replaced with a pawn and this Dragon
Bishop which is the pearl of Black's
position on a lot of these Sicilian
structures it's not spectacular anymore
it's just biting on granite as I like to
say white accentuates the pressure both
sides develop their pieces and the pawn
structure changes again bishop and A5
and white gives up the Knight but in
return He has seriously damaged like
seriously and permanently damaged
Black's Pawn structure will maxulu try
to fix it with D5 well that's the big
question that he is attempting to answer
right now
um yeah and when it comes to Parham you
know he actually said that he was in a
fighting mood yesterday's win against
Jordan van Forrest came as a big relief
to him because of course in round four
he had lost his game to nordebec Abdul
satauroff and you know when you're in a
fighting mood you're gonna take those
aggressive decisions and I agree it's
now or never he has to break out
within the next two or three moves I
mean either you're going to build it by
planting a rook on d8 and then striking
with D5 or
now
the white king is in the center
accelerate the play as quickly as
possible
um the thing that puts me off this is
because I'm by Nature slightly on the
Cowardly side is
I feel that there's two of us and it
could be it could be tactically
vulnerable you know because there's only
one you know there's one attacker one
Defender and as I've learned from the
Soviet School of Chas is that this does
make tactical weaknesses so I was just
considering what's going to happen after
beef I mean if you go D5 Pawn takes and
I was thinking Bishop takes but of
course there is the option of Queen
takes in which case you have to assess
what's going to happen if the queen
steps back but if the bishop takes which
is kind of the move I want to play
because somehow or other I don't quite
wanna trade off Queens and then you have
to think about moves such as B4 whether
that's a pressure
dislodging the queen from its defense of
the bishop
I I'm totally on the same page I don't
think there is a downside to playing a
move like Rook after d8 of course uh you
would be potentially worried about C4
but there's a very minor problem that
move is illegal as long as the king
remains in the center so in terms of
playing it a little bit on the safer
side Rook fd8 makes sense it also makes
sense because it makes D5 stronger not
only does it secure that square but if
you think about a rook sitting on d8
black can recapture with the bishop and
set up some threats against White's
Queen so my evaluation is that the
position is equal but black has to be a
little bit more careful and Parham
careful he has been precise throughout
his event particularly after his win
yesterday against Jordan van force and
we have a very nice interview to bring
to you as the Press caught up with the
Iranian Phenom to talk about his love
for Fighting Chess and how one game turn
your tournament around I really needed
it after that lost to just come back to
the tournament mentally and um and uh
I'm just so happy the way I played I
just I started to attack and I never
stopped it so I'm just so happy with the
result and the way I played I think he
could hold
in that position uh but okay he just in
which position he just I think he just
played like the way that he he was
giving up the whole game I enjoyed and
to play against the players who are
playing like Jordan instead they're like
so aggressive they want to uh withdraw
and play the fighting position I really
enjoyed to play with them also I guess
nobody back was a nice game okay and I
also tried to win he also tried to win
and finally if the result is not draw
and fans are very happy yes
I hope to play more fighting games and
uh I hope I don't make draw anymore
you heard it here first no more dress
get there as Parham maxulu shares his
thoughts after his win against Jordan
benforest he's 22 years old he's
stabilized on right around 27-20 and the
guy just loves chess he's always playing
Blitz and bullet he's always studying I
mean the passion just you can't hide it
when you hear the players share their
thoughts after each game it's it's super
wholesome
yeah it is I really like the fact that
he referenced a game that he won and
again he lost against Abdi sotorov you
know he said he loved that game because
it was real Fighting Chess that they
went for each other and he enjoyed
himself and that is kind of the true
Mark of a great player you know you just
love the game Win Lose draw doesn't
matter it's all about learning it's all
about getting better just improving
every little detail and I mean what a
character I really found that in
interview very exciting very thrilling
and also if I watched it without the
video I would almost say it sounded
exactly like anireza fruition obviously
I'm not talking about just the accent
but the tone and the sound
sounds very similar
no for sure for sure and I think they I
don't know if they're friends they
obviously know each other well uh but
they are united by just just bursting
passion for the game and you know A love
for the game as you said win or lose I
really like that as well I respect that
when players don't just you know move
the losses out of their minds
permanently but you know I had a good
time I enjoyed myself I played a good
game there's nothing to be ashamed of if
you've lost the game great stuff there
from Parham as he contemplates whether
to play D5 or whether to prepare it the
position is going to heat up again and
we will keep a close eye on this game as
it enters the middle game all right I
think we should go back to the bird's
eye view because we've got craziness
going on on some of the boards
particularly in
northern's game they're on the middle of
your screen Wesley's game heating up and
we're at that stage Yogi of the round
we're about an hour and a half in we're
just like all of the games seem to be
offering Breakneck action
yeah absolutely I mean once again you
know they put something in their morning
coffee and they are off and it really
feels like we should check out that game
between Abdullah if I'm pregnant and
because the first thing that catches my
eye is there is a Pawn on C7 now that
pawn probably is not long for the world
but I want to see how it got there
because it does look like it's wild
well I'm kind of mesmerized by this COV
because to understand how it got there
we have to rewind right around to move
15 that's where we left off bishop b6h3
and I kind of predicted that well the
game is going to be quiet for a couple
of moves we're going to see some
maneuvering action no no no abusot Torah
says you moved the Rook away from A8 you
pay the price he plays Bishop C2 induces
G6 and now bang A4
uh posing black with a very impolite
dilemma if you want to give up B5 or do
you want to give up A6 Brock says I want
to give up A6 motorbike doesn't take it
not sure exactly why I think it might
have to do with Queen to C5 attacking C3
and F2 instead motorbike followed
through on his positional idea we had a
trade on C3 and now bang D4 by Prague
just how many Defenders and attackers do
you have on that square I guess it's a
three on three an A5 by notorbeck most
people would go Bishop A7 not Prague he
takes the Knight off the board noterbeck
takes the B6 bishop and we've got Mutual
Armageddon here as the pieces just
disappear from the board Bishop C2 and
BC is the current position so this C7
Pawn started its Journey on a2i always
love tracing the Journey of pieces and
pawns but we need to figure out what's
going on here and I think the best way
to do that is to start by evaluating the
position after Queen takes C7 Queen
takes C2
oh you've interrupted the game with
Checkers that was temporarily being
played sorry
um yeah but I mean yeah totally I mean
this is the key position and okay let's
just do a quick rain check on the
material material is equal and uh the
first thing that I'm kind of noticing is
that okay white has the possibility of
capturing the pawn on D4 or black as the
potential of creating a passport there's
also the pawn lever E5 E6 exploding open
the black king and of course black has
that weak Pawn on a six oh look at you
aren't you going for the checkmates and
of course less than
no forget as Daniel pointing out the
queen killed a plant herself on H6 and
then when the Knight comes sniffing
around well there would be all hell to
pay
yeah that's not exactly my definition of
fun a queen on H6 and an energy five and
that is why in the event of D3 you would
be forgiven for thinking that black is
better here right you've got this
Monster Pawn it's supported by The Rook
White's pawns don't Inspire confidence
but it's just this concrete threat of
dark Square domination on the king side
is incredibly Troublesome you called it
A6 is also weak so well I can't sit on
two chairs here uh to borrow a phrase we
used yesterday either you defend H6 and
give up A6 or you defend A6 and give up
H6 okay that was a tongue twister right
there but I don't think this is an
option for prognananda I think in this
position he's probably best advised to
liquidate with DC try to keep the files
open in the center to make it harder for
white uh to get the queen around to H6
but one thing is very clear to me this
is essentially a two result game unless
Prague finds a way to to spice things up
and he has spite things up
we go back to the live board because
he's played the move Rook to get to C8
he hasn't taken on C7 just yet
it seems to me that he wants to take on
C7 specifically with the Rook
interesting yeah it is very interesting
because okay well now it's a time for
calculation so obviously white is going
to play Queen takes Bishop there's no
other move other than that you're really
going out on a limb there you want I I
think we need to calm down here consider
the Alternatives yeah yeah it takes into
his first okay
okay and then now I know what to do
second you can't take that as you've
highlighted because the night before
and then the kind of options are what do
you do you know C4 is one kind of idea
or do you just throw all caution to the
wind and I kind of like C4
I love C4 because it closes the queen
side and it and it unties your hands or
stuff like E6 which you pointed out
Queenie too
exactly and then you know Queen D2 you
can follow that up with Rook takes porn
queen coming to age six and uh okay so
now the ball is in Black's Court what
should he do to unravel and
the brave warrior in me says hey why
don't you just line up the Rooks on the
same line and just go I don't care or is
E6 the threat I literally don't care
well I'm Gonna Make You Care with Queen
D I'm gonna go Queen D2 here to start to
get the Queen off of the the X-ray
okay and then the night goes to d8 you
know it's a beautiful Square it's ugly
chest but my whole idea is that after
Queen H6 I'm gonna go Queen f8 and say
um
you know my queen she's going to protect
his majesty for as long as possible
indeed well I'm gonna eat up the pun I
haven't had breakfast yet so Knight
takes D4 well it takes you and I think
we're extremely likely in this game to
get an end game like this we've gone
really far down this line but this is
not unlikely I mean you know none of
these moves are are especially crazy and
we could get like a four on three type
situation where blackout clearly has
great drawing chances but let's also not
forget that Prague has used up a chunk
of his time he's down to 42 minutes it
might sound like a lot but he's got 17
moves to make until the time control so
if you're Notre back you're trying to
keep the position as tense and as rich
as possible for as long as possible I
think C4 is a great way to do that and a
great way to force black to make further
decisions you know these open-ended
moves can be especially unpleasant when
your clock dwindles down below 30
minutes
um yeah definitely and even this end
game you know if if you kind of look at
it you know four versus three if they
were just Rooks on the board clear draw
but even then there's still a lot of
danger because the more pawns they are
on the board the higher the winning
chances but you know then when you add
in Rook two Rooks a night
it becomes dangerous and again not so
easy to assess and especially if you
don't have so much time on the clock
like you mentioned
um yeah it's it's a full-on fight in the
battle between teenagers
it is but Notre back is on fire I mean
he's playing quickly he's playing
confidently and he is applying so much
pressure with both colors here I mean
this is the ultimate sign of someone
who's in killer form it's just like
every game he's he's in the driver's
seat whether he wins or draws so we will
keep an eye on Note Rebecca
abdusitorov's attempt to expand and
extend his lead which might be necessary
because Anish Geary is sitting very
pretty against Arch and aragaisy but
before we bring you an update on that
game and others as we look at the bird's
eye view here we will go on our second
break of the day we're an hour and 40
minutes into round six of Tata steel
this historic 85th edition of Tata steel
we hope you've been enjoying our
coverage and we will have more Tata
Steel action for you on the other side
of this break
I forgot
[Music]
foreign
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now right here almost there and you did
it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lapse yeah okay you bring a clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get something to eat okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
s
for this cozy coastal town the holiday
season isn't over
in fact the most wonderful time of the
year has really just begun motorbike
just playing a modern brilliancy there
it is a sensational moment
once again Vicon say starts the new year
as the center of the chess Universe this
year as host of the 85th Tata steel
chess tournament
a magnet for the best players in the
game some recognize the Masters field of
2023 as its strongest in recent memory
of course it helps win eight-time Tata
steel chess champion Magnus Carlson is
back can the world champion demonstrate
that resilience which has accompanied
him for his entire chess career the
world's number one looks to further
cement his legacy in this event and the
game's history
chasing Magnus will be amongst the best
in chess several have been crowned
Champion here before some have even
shocked the world in doing so
and don't leave out those poised to
capture their first Tata title Anish is
taking down the world champion Magnus in
absolute shock
although winter Tata steel chess is also
known as the place new stars come to
bloom Magnus one here is a teenager this
year's event has its fair share of young
players on the rise each hoping to
follow in Carlson's footsteps big
results Parham maxi
the first win
the Dutch refer to Tata steel as The
Wimbledon of chess for 85 years in
running this tournament continues to be
steeped in Prestige and Legacy and does
so again in this welcoming Little Dutch
town by the sea
mind Brendan it's the 85th edition of
the Tata steel chess tournament and it
starts right now
entering the second hour in round six of
this 85th edition of the Tata steel
chess tournament the most prestigious uh
and anticipated event annually and we
will update you first and foremost on
the current leaderboard round six is in
progress let's take a quick look at the
standings after five rounds some dude
named Notre back abdusitorov leads he
hasn't really won any tournaments before
hasn't beaten any good players this
tournament only the world champion he's
on 4 out of five Anish giri trailing
close second with three and a half what
a tight tightly packed field we have and
what a second half of the tournament
we're going to have you'll be guaranteed
fun
yeah absolutely you know so many people
all sniffing around the top you know
fabby's not far behind levonne aronia
and pragnananda and uh let's take a look
at the bottom though because all the way
languishing in 10th place is the war
champ Magnus Carlson you know someone
who's won Tata steel eight times well he
didn't get the best stuff starts and I
say that in the very British way
an understatement of the year so far but
okay still only five rounds played
plenty more to go it is a marathon and
things are gonna be heating up that is
for sure and uh well do you think
they're any realistically there are any
chances for those people say Vincent
kaima Jordan van Forest good cash any
chances for them to suddenly kind of
have this Alleluia moment where
everything clicks and they start playing
fantastically well it's happened before
well I'm not a betting man but if I were
to bet on somebody having that
Hallelujah moment of course I'm not
going to say anything revolutionary here
I think Magnus Carlson as a pretty good
shot at it but it all starts with
getting back to 50 and Magnus is not
used to to telling himself yeah one game
at a time first let me get out of the
gutter I mean these are not words that
he ever speaks to himself we just take
it for granted that a disastrous
performance from Magnus Carlson is 50
minus one is unheard of but for players
like ukesh and kymer they've been
struggling and they're continuing to
struggle as we look at our bird's eye
view here you know some games remain
relatively calm I mean the calmest game
is ding against irony and that seems
like a pretty balanced equal middle game
still we have an imbalance in that white
as the iqp so we'll keep you posted on
that game but we've got some crazy stuff
going on on the rightmost game Fabiano
caruana is taking it to gukesh he is
crushing him he is smash rushing through
the gates and I think we need to go to
that game uh yovi because this could be
one of the most disastrous games of
gukesh's career it's moved 17 and unless
I'm missing something cataclysmic I
think this is borderline resignable
uh yeah and it's quite funny because we
were here just a few moments ago and we
said the position was bad
but what on Earth happened to make it
this disastrous
um because we saw a very surprising move
right I mean I mean when we were
discussing this position I did for a
brief second think about putting the
queen or CH just to try to get some
counter attack and I dismiss it as
quickly as I could because I realized
off the bishop takes Knight Pawn takes
the queen can come to F6 attacking the
Knight
and of course if there's one thing I
learned in my chess career you do not
want a queen on F6 standing so close to
your king that is a nightmare this F6
square is like the perfect thing for a
queen to be on and of course the Knight
moved over to G6 to try to get as close
to the king as possible and uh well
slam dunk yeah I was gonna say caveman
Fabby here you know he's really just
going for broke he just wants H5 H6 and
uh give a Checkmate on G7 incidentally
do you know what the Checkmate on G7 is
called
is well I know Lobster pinsirisah hikara
refers to it is there a formal name yeah
there is it doesn't sound anything as
cool as uh Lobster pincer though uh it's
it's I hate Lobster so tell me yeah it's
called the lollies mate after lolly
lolly the study and the composer in the
in previous times
yeah I don't know what I don't know what
he was I can't really remember whether
he was a composer I think he was a
player but uh yeah
Lolly is the name Lolly's mate we like
us at ice Lolly
it does sound British although that
could also be Italian
wait wait what uh okay so that went a
bit high pitched there I'm sorry I think
I see this idea I think I see his idea
so first of all let me just clarify we
Americans aren't really known for our
understatement Queen C8 makes absolutely
no sense to me it just seems like kukesh
you know he's he's out of sorts this
tournament and when you get a bad
position and you're already in bad form
you know Panic strikes even the
strongest and most experienced players
now what is his idea his idea is to meet
H5 I'm positive and this is the only
move with Rook to F5 very creative and
while this dislodges the queen from F6
and you're not going to get Lolly mated
but what you are going to get is a
totally devastating attack and there is
a second idea that was set up with the
movie tribe and that is the classic Rook
lift from H4 H3 uh to G4 or G3 and all
that white really needs to do here is
bring the queen all the way back don't
put it on B2 because then black has the
very nasty Intermezzo C3 don't put it on
D4 because you're running into Rook D5
so I mean A1 is forced by process of
elimination after 97 Rook H4 another
double attack you're threatening
Checkmate black has to make this ugly
move
white can give a check first but white
can simply play the very easy move
Bishop takes C4 and then just look at
this position black is devastated on the
king side he is down upon white still
has the idea of going H6 I don't think
that this is quite residable I think
that was an exaggeration but if Fabi
reaches this position and I'm quite
positive that he will
two three four more accurate moves and
we could have a 1-0 on the tournament
cross table this is likely to be the
first game to end
yeah
I have to say I mean those moves look
pretty forcing to me I mean yeah I
panicked a little bit after pointe's
Pawn but I calmed down after five
and uh yeah still a fight somewhat but I
agree with you ultimately I mean just
just look at the position you have on
the analysis board seemed relatively
forced and just devastating I mean
you're not gonna come back from having
your king just so exposed there on G8
and uh White has fantastic piece
coordination as well with the Rooks and
yeah those two things combined make a
deadly Duo so um
bad news for good cash
this is this is sad and you know we go
back to the live board here the other
problem is that Fabio says no other
moves right they're the worst kind of
situations when you are compelled to
make the Right Moves it's such a tilting
sensation because you don't even have uh
the possibility of inducing a blunder
but what's interesting about this game
is not just the position that's on the
board it's the sort of background and
the players uh the Arc of their career I
mean the Arc of gukesha's career has
gone in Only One Direction and that is
straight up at such an interesting
statistic there Yobe that I'd I'll ask
your thoughts on go cash gain 111 rating
points during the same period in 2022
right about a year that carwana dropped
26 rating points and carwana struggles
uh in the last year a year and a half
have been well publicized we know he had
that collapse of the candidates he
struggled at the U.S Championship you
know he lost 2 800 but Fabiano has
proven himself as one of the most
resilient players of all time he just
doesn't not let these bad performances
get to him and he plays with such
consistency and just such
professionalism even when he goes
through a bad stretch of his career but
really some very interesting factoids
there cash making his debut didn't know
that either
no I I didn't know that kakesh was
making a debut but of course it was not
really surprising that gakesh gained 111
rating points and you called it what you
had on the analysis board is on the
board right now although the queen has
come to C3
that one looks equally good I mean the
only difference I can see nope no
difference
well Fabiano playing like like someone
who's made 13 appearances he's like I
know the drill I'm playing confidently
and uh I don't think this changes all
that much by the way Queen C3 Queen A1 I
mean it's gonna be the same type of
position uh we're gonna see Fabi taking
on C4 and this is lost this is this is
flat Outlast
yeah absolutely now I was just thinking
about
um carowana's kind of rating drop
one Trend that I have seen quite a bit
is that the juniors are kind of gaining
a load of rating points like like 111
does not surprise me I mean I've seen
Juniors gain like 200 points in a year I
mean it's that much and everyone else
meanwhile has been dropping like it's
not that out of the ordinary to see
someone I mean I'm speaking for my own
personal experience I've dropped quite a
significant amount my rating I just
wondering whether this is maybe
something leveling out and that the
corona pandemic has kind of caused a
little bit of this that the people who
were so dangerous were very severely
underrated and uh one kind of very
natural case in points was I do remember
in
2022 Blitz that the Indian Juniors were
all playing in the rapid and Blitz with
like some ridiculous rating of 2200
and just matching everybody's waiting
points much to the Grand Masters Fury
they said this is not fair why are they
why are they doing this to us we've
worked so hard for our rating we've
worked for years and they come with this
ridiculously artificial low rating and
uh when the rating prizes and I'm just
joking and
grab every single thing
um yeah but I mean I mean once this
leveling and what I'm trying to say is
like once this leveling has occurred I'm
expecting that everyone who's lost those
rating points will slowly inch their way
back well I'm hoping at least wishful
thinking on my part
yeah I I think uh some people get too
excited about this process and they say
well you know this just shows that in
people like Fabi and nepo who by the way
has avoided largely dodged the sort of
great rating loss uh they didn't belong
there in the first place and they're
actually you know 2600 no no there's a
very good reason that the super GMS are
who they are and I agree that there will
be a little bit of a counter correction
uh after this radical process has taken
place but just to your point when you
look at tournaments held in India it is
very standard to see a bunch of European
Grandmasters just losing round one to
like a 1900 to 2000 and in very
one-sided fashion so India is just a
terrifying place to play chess right now
I mean obviously the chess culture is
booming and we're not just talking about
the grand Masters and the Arya Guy
season gukashas that now have a
reputation as incredibly fearsome super
Grand Masters we're also talking about
the new crop of young players who are 21
and 2200
um and and are vastly underrated and who
are already bringing up the rear so to
speak and are also making a bid to one
day enter uh the chess Elite but
unfortunately this tournament just has
not been on gukesh's side but it says
only his first appearance inside of
Steel he has so many years ahead of him
as he moves his Knight back to E7 he
faces down the barrel of a lost position
and we'll see if Fabby who seems
incredibly relaxed can finish this game
off
yeah uh Fabi is a very good chess player
and that's the understatement of the
Year having played him myself in a
classical game I can kind of testify
like how calculating he is how focused
how he plays with deadly Precision
because he calculates everything you
know I remember our game I was shaking
with nerves at the beginning and then he
kind of played something that I didn't
expect and then I thought hang on a
second I'm okay in fact maybe I think
I'm slightly better and I got very
excited and uh anyhow he gave me the
opportunity to sacrifice a piece I did
like a fool I walked into the traps and
I was like okay his King cannot survive
in the center but guess what he had
calculated every single detail and it
was a tragic mistake that I had made and
that was it interesting it might have
been but Fabi was one step ahead
as he often is and he has a calculating
machine but he's adjusted his style he's
gotten better at Blitz as well so I I
really love the way in which Fabi has
become a more multifaceted player in the
last couple of years some incredible
performances and online events uh that
have really corrected his course uh that
that started in very unpleasant fashion
from the U.S championship and then went
moved on to the candidates Fabby seems
more confident he seems more fresh and I
know he loves Tata steel I know from
firsthand experience that that is his
favorite tournament that's what he uh
told us in Toronto and you could just
see the inspiration in fabi's play all
right let's go back to the bird's eye
view because we have some really
exciting developments on a couple of
other boards the world champion has the
kind of ending that we predicted yo I
mean it's exactly the kind of ending he
wants he's got that Bishop on E5 and
Knight on F6 he's got a big big clamp in
the center and even has a Pawn on G five
so he's now working on King side
expansion maybe trying to shatter
White's Pawn chain G2 F3 E4 so Magnus I
think really could not be happier at the
game at the way his game is unfolding at
the same time I would not say that he is
objectively better I just think he's got
the kind of position he prefers to have
yeah I agree with you he's excellent in
that type of position I mean he's got
everything he wants white has once bad
piece the Knight on A2 and he's also
doing his kind of calling card I've seen
him do it so many times he takes as much
space as possible with his pawns and he
gets them ready for great in-game
positions uh he's uh breaking down for
the Long Haul I think and I
ultimately the game might end in a draw
but I guarantee you it will be Magnus
who is pressing and pushing hard here
yeah this is just this is just vintage
Magnus Carlson it's been a while since
we've checked into the Anish giri game
what's interesting is that only a couple
of moves have been played since we last
examined it but I vote we take another
look at the Geary game to see how Eric
icy's defensive effort is progressing
yeah definitely I mean when we left it
that position was red hot full of
complications full of fire and uh I
still is judging from the position but I
mean has anything changed significantly
I I think we've gotten more clarity on
how the game is likely to unfold in the
next couple of moves first of all the
reason we've only had a couple of moves
and I made a false assumption I assumed
Eric icy would have 10 minutes right now
but instead the clock situation has
equalized and the move I think that took
Anish giri a very long time is this move
Rook a to C1 he brings the Rook to C1
preemptively and it might seem like an
empty move it might seem like the C4
Pawn is unassailable but it's not as
unassailable as as it appears because
the bishop on D5 is itself not
unassailable and white proves that by
putting his own Bishop on e4 on the next
move you could bring the other Rook over
to D1 at the same time Arjun is trying
to orchestrate some counter play along
the f file so it is still a very
double-edged position Knight takes E5
needs to be seriously calculated here
and this could explode into chaos really
at any moment it would if black takes on
E5
oh
I
was thinking that maybe not possible
because uh you know radical times call
for radical measures I know that's not
really the expression but after Knight
takes Queen takes I was thinking Rook
takes born
yeah I was wanting to do it the previous
move but then I realized that that
wasn't possible and okay and
Bishop B7
Queen takes E5 now it's not in well it
is over because the problem is it's not
the material advantage that's the
problem it's it's the state the sorry
state of black skin that's Bishop gonna
drop back and look at those juicy dark
squares the king is not long for this
board what a line Rook takes C4 and
Bishop B7 I love combinations that
revolve around discovered checks like
the Discover checks such a simple device
and yet so powerful such a game changer
in a lot of these tactical positions
yeah and uh the fact that he lined up
his Rook on C1 shows that he's thinking
about the possibility of playing Rook
takes Pawn it's in the air now it
doesn't work right now because after
after Bishops
who would be on the receiving end of
that discovered check tactic but uh yeah
it's definitely Brewing
I guess what's hard is just figuring out
what to do if your Argent the move that
instinctively came to me is Knight D7 to
B6 just try to buttress you know these
two weak points on C4 and D5 and make
sure that white doesn't crash through
but Anish has a just a steady supply of
moves that are not too committal and
that improve his position an example of
such a move is just A4 now you might say
well this is a blunder but the more
files are open on the queen side the
better it is for Anish you can now swing
his Rook at Rook A1 there's Knight C3 I
guess
but you know just Rook F to D1 right he
can make a lot of these moves and apply
pressure on the center and he's not
really risking much
yeah you can keep it going like for
instance you can inverse this two moves
you can go Rook D1 first and then put
maximum pressure on that bishop and then
if black doesn't nothing kind of move
um A4
is coming
and uh six I guess G5 isn't very good I
mean I have to see like where's the
bishop gonna go I mean first thing it's
gonna go like hit it back oh
that is full board Vision there I love
it Bishop goes to A4 and
oh
pin and win
in its most brutal sense
that's the right side effect you just
made there yeah
yeah it was like kind of take it back
take it back I don't want to see that um
uh okay so how is black gonna defend
because that looked
nasty
I mean I mean yeah
Queen C6 queen queen is a good Defender
right
oh Queen 64 almost works but the bishop
actually takes the bishop not the queen
oh my voice cracked there but what about
a move like Knight F3 to D2 this gets
really crazy because now black can take
on E5 so maybe this isn't quite as
effective
okay you can can you please play calmly
and say okay you've put pressure on the
bishop just go yeah no problem what do
you want no problem at all because
trading pieces doesn't help black he
loses C4
exactly and again the ball is in Black's
chords and like has to come up with a
move
not easy ideally you kind of want to
pass right
and you just kind of maybe pick up a
pawn from off the board and put it back
on B7 or B5 and I hope your opponent
doesn't notice yeah you put a Pawn on B5
the whole landscape changes like black
would be winning with the pawn with an
extra Pawn sitting on B5 if you added
the pawns back to B2 and B5 black would
be in in just incomparably better shape
but you know at the risk of sounding
like a San Francisco hippie you can just
sense the energy in Anish giri's play it
gives off a certain wavelength a certain
Vibe and that Vibe just speaks to
someone who's hungry for a win in every
game his openings are fresh he's finding
ideas every game you know he's playing
ambitiously with both colors and just to
top all of that off we have such a great
interview of Anish from yesterday's game
uh over in the Amsterdam Johann kreif
Arena it's just awesome to hear somebody
in good form share his thoughts so let's
listen in
well first of all here are my two
sponsors I have here after here
adjustable they're written down but it's
very cool so I'll cover them for now
after this very respectful shout out
okay okay now um no it's very easy it's
a little bit like your birthday
everybody kind of lets you and you just
try it on your Facebook wall or whatever
thank you all and number one with your
life people sometimes say that they come
all the way from I don't believe them
honestly I don't believe them I don't
think uh they apply just to see I think
they actually have some things to do and
uh they use this it sounds good yeah I
use it as an excuse yeah I don't believe
that anyone would fly actually all the
way to to get a picture with me I just I
just don't buy that it's really really
nice but I just don't buy it at all
hahaha
you're scary ladies and gentlemen any
scary he's it's he speaks for himself
doesn't he yeah people would fly all
across the world just a chapter a niche
right
I think they would
Maybe not maybe yes always you can
always count them for entertainment
that's one thing is for certain yeah no
I mean he was quite he was quite happy
there I mean he could kind of sense the
relief because I don't think he was
looking forward to playing Prague you
know he felt that that was a shadow
looming Over the Horizon and of course
to neutralize him with the black pieces
I mean that would have been a relief
because when you're at the top of the
table as he was uh after round four then
you kind of just want to maintain the
pressure starts intensifying and ah it
was nice nice interview I I really do
like Anish for me he's uh one of the
greatest guys out there got a lot of
time for him
he's flamboyant he's energetic he's
approachable and this is what we need
and she has we need people like that to
make top GM chess accessible and
approachable and interesting for people
who aren't necessarily super invested
into the game itself I think this is the
best time to be alive uh because chess
is just such an entertaining game now
the personalities are interesting even
if you're still learning how the pieces
move but speaking of how pieces are
moving Vincent kymer's pieces are not
moving at all let's take a quick look
back on our bird's eye view and then
let's fly on over to Wesley so
International Airport because he's got a
rook that's sitting pretty on D7 yovi I
mean some of the other games are getting
interesting as well by the way we
predicted what would happen in
notorbeck's game we have exactly the
kind of scenario we thought might happen
a four on three but the Queens are still
on the board they're likely to get
traded though so that's a classic 50 50
game Notre Beck is going to push for a
win is there anything else catching your
eye before we take a look no this is the
main things those were the absolute main
things I was also going to complement
our fortune telling skills as well
against uh in the game between naughty
Beck and Prague I was going to say
our services of telling the future are
up for hire and uh anyhow let's race the
game between Wesley and Vincent because
yeah like you say that Rook on D7 that's
a face and piece
oh my gosh I'm still adjusting my eyes
to to What's Happening Here I think it
would be worthwhile given how unique
this position is uh to to rewind let's
say uh 10 moves or so and just see how
this went from a very standard rui Lopez
to total chaos and Anarchy on the board
so we had a normal rule Lopez the
craziness really started with the move
d4 because that led to a mass trade in
the center Wesley driving his Pawn up
and then Vincent says my pieces are
passive so I'm gonna compensate by
gobbling up Wesley's A5 Fawn and he does
Wesley says take my Pawn I'm going to
focus on clamping down in the center
Knight D2 the Knight is driven out to F3
where it threatens to move into G5 and
so Vincent has to spend a Tempo
preventing that look at Wesley's
development advantage and how much more
activist pieces are and Vincent tries to
solve the problem by dancing his Queen
around Wesley keeps intensifying the
pressure and then there's a trade of
Bishops and Wesley goes after Vincent's
extra Pawn which he wins back with Rook
takes D7 this is on the board now it may
seem like white is totally winning and
that is what I thought initially but the
more I look at it the more I realize the
black is a very interesting defensive
resource the move Queen B7 to C8 puts
the rook in a very compromised spot and
leads to some wild tactical
complications do you think that move is
sensible yeah I I do like that move I
hadn't seen it I must admit
that's in another move which is Rook d8
so a good old-fashioned back ranker and
if he goes E6
then you could just simply go Knight
takes born give up oh oh that is sick
and if you take the queen
oh that was my voice is cracking Rook D1
that was not my finest Hour this is back
rank check this would not be the white
King's finest Hour E6 is a very
important resource to keep tabs on
but can white successfully navigate this
tension on the D file I guess Wesley
would maybe take on d8 and go Queen to
D7
but then there's Queen to D5 oh that's
nice it's better in this end game who
knows how about them
yeah
okay so what's the move here why is the
eval bar so optimistic
is it because oh my gosh there's E6 and
95 but that gets too wild to calculate
gosh I really don't want to flip the
engine on here
is it something so calm as H4 you know
knowing computers it's it's always
something
it's not a bad move I think H4 keeps an
advantage
yeah but then you can do your queen CA
idea
here I guess I'll play and now you can
get eaten oh
it takes we're getting there and
I have to take the Rook because
otherwise you lose either The Rook or
the queen and black is I wouldn't say
Out of the Woods I mean even here Queen
E5 and you have to move the Knight and
then I take E6 which you could still get
checkmated with this Knight coming out
to E5 so this is honestly a pretty
depressing reality for Vincent I think
you should seek his fortunes elsewhere
and perhaps start with Queen C8 so shall
we have a quick look at that move yeah
and how the game could unfold so Queen
see it obviously you can't take the
bishop so ideally you want the queen uh
to be protected but it's not so easy to
move the queen onto a protected Square
move it back to D3 run into Rook d8 I
guess he could move it back to H3 but
then your idea still Rook T8 and you
haven't solved the back ring problem
okay huh
and uh what about being
calm about this I mean do you need to
move the queen can you go
I was just wondering whether you could
prepare for the end game with some quiet
move
ah like
no E6 didn't quite work because the pawn
takes
and then yeah
oh yeah goodbye
and so I was kind of looking at moves
like age three
down
don't laugh I think you have you know
just oh no I think that's the best
yeah I know I didn't know but I was just
thinking H3 and then but then for d8 and
then
you kind of I mean do you not have to go
can you go
if you can't do E6 well you can maybe
you can no do E6 because yeah you have
to do it otherwise it takes workers
nothing and this transposes essentially
into the line we were just analyzing
this queen E5 moves actually super super
important because it dislodges the
Knight and you win back E6 with interest
so I love them of H3 I think this gives
black you know a lot of rope and so
maybe Rook d8 is Hasty maybe black needs
to play I don't know maybe G6 first or
some like computer move like C4 to keep
the tension and deprive white of the D3
Square
but yeah to make a long story short I
mean it's a super complex position I
think White's got the upper hand
practically speaking but given the eval
bar is showing equality I think Queen C8
holds the balance if Vincent can
continue playing accurately Wesley's
also a little bit low on time
yeah wow what amazing complications it
is very amazing I have to say I love
your move C4
and that's a final analysis position
because yeah it is the kind of move that
a computer would play I'm not a big fan
of G6 because you're weakening your own
King but C4 take the space be super calm
about it love it
um
the question though is I mean do you
think Vincent will play the very calm
Queen Retreat or do you think he will be
swayed by this tactical idea of playing
rook d8 and then check mating along the
back rank
I'm worried that it will be the latter
because that line we calculated with
Rook d8 Rook takes d8 and then Queen D7
which runs into Queen D5 when you see a
line like this it really raises the
appeal of Rook D and the appeal of Rook
did is already very high because it
forces the Rooks off the board and
that's an incredibly natural thing to do
the move E6 which I think is the only
way
um well actually no E6 there's Knight
takes C6 I already forgot what the best
food was after rookdale we just thought
white might be three there h3o H yeah
it's not easy to appreciate the power of
a move like H3 even though it actually
is a very powerful concept to create
some Luft and renew the threat of taking
on E7 so
man what a difficult Choice here for
Vincent he might conceivably take 20 or
30 minutes here he's got plenty of time
and and he senses obviously that this is
a critical moment that responding
correctly uh is is crucial if he wants
White's initiative to fizzle out here
one day
yeah and uh let's go back to the bird's
eye view and uh have a look at uh some
of the other games and we haven't caught
up with a
Magnus in a long time maybe we should go
and see how he's doing because last time
we kind of mentioned that he was doing
okay he was in his comfort zone he was
going to start massaging an in-game
advantage from probably nowhere but uh
it is the way he plays chess and uh he's
not out there to win friends
he is doing exactly that right he's he's
already in the driver's seat no question
about that I think Jordan will have to
play accurately in the next couple of
moves if he wants to maintain equality
so what's going on here well first of
all let's bring everybody up to speed on
the last couple of moves
um Magnus played the move G5 here to
expand on the king side and really carve
out the dark squares for himself
then he went Rook G8 A4 moves met with
B4 Jordan trying to force Black's pawns
forward and weaken the A5 fund you have
this very typical maneuver Knight C1
Knight B3 instead he goes C3
basically carving the path back to C3
Magnus strikes in the center we have a
trade leaving us only with Bishops and
Rooks
and after Rook C1 King F6 I love what
Jordan has just done Bishop E2 to C4 not
procrastinating saying get off me get
off D5 and if the Bishops are traded
Yobe I feel like the result is not
really going to be in question
yeah that was a great move by Jordan you
know because it is Black's best piece
isn't it as you say
um but is there any way that Magnus can
try something because after all it's a
question of poor majorities and when you
have the situation in end games it's
often who is able to create that past
pawn and uh say all the Rooks come off
then I think white is the one who will
benefit because after all he has an
outside pass pawn and it's very easy to
create I'm born from those two
um but in with the Rooks on the board
and especially four pieces
um we can see something happening right
I'm I'm just going to think that maybe
Magnus will start to clamp down on this
majority on the queen side and then all
the while extends something I mean how
is he looking let's have a look at the
camera no he doesn't look that happy so
I'm kind of probably overthinking
and just coming to these kind of
conclusions just because it is Magnus
playing this game
yeah there is a Magnus effect that
relates to commentators which that I
personally always it's like you
subconsciously give him the benefit of
the doubt if it's an equal end game you
automatically think he's slightly better
now he's gone Bishop B7 it is a sensible
decision to keep the Bishops on the
board you know accentuating the
possibility of G4 which would open up
the diagonal and White's Bishop right
now isn't the most impressive piece and
that is why if I'm Jordan I'm seriously
contemplating the move Bishop C4 to B5
with many ideas it paves the way for a
rook infiltration it sets up a potential
Bishop trade on C6 and in response to
Bishop B5 off the top of my head I don't
see all that much that Magnus could do
other than to go back to D5 and I would
not say that it's out of the question we
will see a repetition of moves here
Magnus is not going to do anything wild
or foolish just to say that he's playing
for a win he definitely does not want us
lose a third game in a row so yeah if
Jordan plays Bishop B5 unless Magnus
finds a compelling way to keep chances
alive and keep the inherent imbalance uh
alive he might go back to D5
mm-hmm ah it's a very real possibility I
agree with you I mean White's done
nothing wrong and his pieces are well
placed and uh let's have a look at uh
Carlson's performance in previous years
and uh there we can see that in 2022 he
came first with an amazing score you
know and then sixth in 2021 I remember
that year because I actually commented
on that a Norwegian TV and every time I
commented he lost and I was like oh no
I'm clearly jinxing him here and uh yeah
and in 2020 it was Fabi who took the
title back and otherwise though in 2019
2018 it's just been Magnus all the way
and uh
it's incredible actually that he didn't
lose a game at all in 2018 2019
um I don't don't think he lost anything
in 2022 either
so no he didn't and there is a rather
disturbing statistic which is that
Magnus has never won vikon's a without
winning in the first five rounds okay so
the years that he won he scored at least
one victory in the first five rounds of
course here uh he did score a victory in
the first five rounds that's easy to
forget he did beat Vincent kymer so
technically he has fulfilled checked
that box and that means it's still
possible for him uh to win and he's only
lost 14 out of the 195 games that he has
played which is not magnus's best
tournament record if you think about
Magnus 14 out of 195 that's more more
losses than the averages in regular
chess so his performance in Tada has
been rather uneven for magnus's
standards which is to say he's only won
like 50 percent of Tata Steels that he's
played in but the crazy stat which we
repeated earlier is that the last time
he lost two games in a row was Norway
chess
2015. just think about that for a second
think about how much he plays and how
crazy it is that he hasn't lost two
games in a row in eight years I mean
mind-boggling honestly yeah and uh he
talked about crazy moves and
mind-boggling moves I have to say I was
completely flawed by Jordan's last move
on the board you know because we were
you were talking about playing Bishop E5
and perhaps we would see a three-fold
repetition while the two Bishops danced
on the D5 B7 square and instead Jordan
is like hey
I'm gonna play B4 I'm gonna try to
simplify the position as much as
possible and
I'm surprised by this because I didn't
actually think that white could play
like it because I thought if the bishop
came to B5 then the black porn that is
under threat could actually move itself
forward and as you've highlighted the
bishop come to its defense and okay
Jordan Jordan's idea was simply to park
the bishop on B3 and to just liquidate
things that way and
I I like it actually now that I've kind
of taken my jaw off the floor
I like what he's done it's simple
and simple chess is always good
especially when you're playing the world
champion and you're having a bad
tournament and you need to study the
ship the last thing you need is to lose
again
this game is going to end in a draw I'm
about 90 certain just because you know
Magnus needs a spark to start the flame
right he can't just win an end game
on the basis of his reputation alone you
actually need to create imbalances and
the thing is
White's taking on B4 on the very next
move this past Apon is going to be a
major asset for white it also is sort of
a weakness and a strength at the same
time you need to dedicate at least a
rook and a bishop to holding it together
but just the issue is Magnus hasn't
started the engine on the other side of
the board I suppose he can try to go H5
and G4 but the thing is even if he does
that and Jordan just takes on G4 the f
file opens and then Magnus will have to
watch out for you know Rick F1 check or
Rook C7 so I really think this position
is is incredibly balanced and one way
that the game could liquidate is
something like Rook V8 Rook takes before
and then you have this check on e4 uh
then you take on B3
I think we're gonna get some sort of
double Rook end game which is going to
end in a repetition if I really had to
guess at this moment of course we've
seen Magnus pull off anything obviously
yeah and uh and times to your earlier
points I mean one move that I was
particularly attracted to but actually
does not work was actually to pull the
trigger now and play G4 with the idea
being you know now that white has to use
at the time to grab on B4 but that
really doesn't work because of Rook F4
check ooh and rookie and then the Rook
C7 comes and it's like oh dear yeah the
plan the plan is completing the
backfires
I don't want to do that one at home uh
yes so
um
so how to I mean and in light of that
there's just no way to get to use that
extra tempo
I mean and something maybe I was
thinking you could do is put your Bishop
on A6 to try to improve the bishop so
when The Rook does capture on B4 it goes
to D3
this is like okay I move my offered okay
I was thinking more of along the lines
of Pastor C check Pat's a place check
that's it I like that I like that
expression
I like that expression me too me too me
too it's one of my favorites and
sometimes very relevant especially in
time travel you know when the tension is
too much and you can't think of what to
play of your life like ah check check
and then afterwards you're like why on
Earth did I do that so my coach
um whom I trained with for many years
left sack is he he would always make
this Insight which is one of those
things that you roll your eyes at when
you first hear and then you know it's
like you think about it more you you get
older and you realize those are very
wise words he told me that very often
when you don't know what to do in a rook
end game you want to give a check like
checks have a certain inherent value in
the end game which kind of makes sense
because they essentially win Tempi and
they allow you to get your pieces to
better squares they also force your
opponent to decide where to commit to a
particular King placement and The more
I've analyzed end games the more I
realized his words are actually really
wise when you have a dilemma and you're
not sure what to play often just giving
the check is at the very least a pretty
safe bet but unfortunately this is not a
rook end game and I think the presence
of Bishops cancels out the effectiveness
of a check on D3 or a check on B8 the
king can always kind of hide in the
corner if things get uh iffy on the
queen side so in any case I think Jordan
is holding this very comfortably I think
the move B4 is excellent it shows that
he's not afraid and he's going to play
with an iron fist he doesn't just want
to draw from a position of weakness he
wants to draw from a position of
strength
um yeah I agree and uh I I love what
Jordan's done I I think
it's just simplifying the position so
it's very simple you know and also that
porn on A4 it is like a North star it's
gonna guide him as to what he wants to
do which is just push that phone I mean
how much easier is that meanwhile as you
kind of pointed out quite quite a few
times you know black is not really doing
anything on the king side I mean he
really needs to get three moves in you
know he needs to go H5 H4 H3 before he
can destabilize those three pawns there
so yeah I think offer a draw is is a
good practical choice for Magnus
it is and he's not allowed
he's not allowed he's not going to I
think he's I think he'd rather take a
repetition than than a draw for he has
averaged one loss per year at Tata steel
and he's already exceeded his allotment
of losses so I had to bet I would
probably bet that Magnus won't lose any
more games and taught his steal but
that's not enough he's also got to win
games with both colors if he wants to
make a bid at the very least for the top
three and as the world champion Ponders
his next move both players with plenty
of times we're unlikely to see a Time
scramble here and I think a good
opportunity for us to go back to the
bird's eye view with a lot of the games
really at different stages the Maxwell
report game has only just really made
its way into the middle game while the
updos to tour of game is just knocking
on the door of an end game should the
Queen's get traded Vincent kymer has
indeed played Rook d8 so let's Pat
ourselves on the back he's done it and
will Wesley find a way to keep the
tension with a move like H3 that's going
to be exciting the ding game is also
getting pretty exciting but Yogi I'll
give you the final say on where we go
next I think we have to go to ding
against Levon because we haven't seen
that game in a long time I mean we're
kind of saying that things were setting
themselves up rather nicely for a lot of
action and uh here well we have an
unorthodox position because both sides
have their Pawn weaknesses both sides
are very active with their Rooks
um it feels like there's a position
where it's not really clear who's
attacking and who's going to be
defending actually
yeah they're locked in this in this
headlock where you look at it from the
side yeah you're like wait who is the
one actually pressing on the gas pedal
here and the answer I think is that they
both are but you know White's got a
Ferrari and black has like a Toyota
Camry so I think White's pressure
exceeds what Levon aronian has going
against the D4 Pawn which is very safely
defended ding brought his ape on up to
A5 partially to fix Lex Queen side and
fix the weakness on Visa but also to
pave the way for the move that he has
just played Rook A1 to A4 is just a sick
way to defend the pawn and he's got a
lot of stuff going for him other than
the attack on E6 he's threatening B7
that knight from D3 has a phenomenal
prospect on C5
that Rook on E5 is right in Black's
Grail and it's very hard to attack so to
me there's no question that Ding is
better the hard part is determining the
extent of his advantages he much better
is he a little bit better yobi what does
your intuition suggest
um I have to say I'm still unsure X
I'm very unsure as to what's happening
here because
you know there's pressure against the
default Pawn I'm never gonna discount
that one because you mean I mean black
could even play a radical moves such as
B5 and uh yeah the a pawn would not be
up for grabs because of this a hit on D4
and uh something I would always be
thinking about is moves like D5 is this
going to be a problem for black
and if it is then I'm going to do
something about it if not
um it's just because I favor positions
where I'm playing against the iqb I'll
be honest with you
it's just my personal prejudices coming
into play you know I'm thinking ah it's
okay it's all good and
it's enough it's enough to hold any
disadvantage
yeah I mean why does an iqb isolated
Queen Bond I would suppose black has an
ikp that does not roll off the tongue an
isolated King Pawn I think the reason
that's not like a normal abbreviation is
because the iqp structure is very common
and it occurs in a lot of openings so it
makes sense to have a specific term for
it you do get isolated King pawns once
in a while but it's not sort of part of
a larger type of structure that is worth
understanding but I really like your
move B5 like when you mention that I've
been
looking at it excitedly and I think it
is a good way to try to solve black
problems concretely like if we pull up
an announcement B5 if white blindly
stumbles into Rook takes A6 I think Rook
takes D4 just wins the game for black
whoop and the queen is overloaded
so you can't do that neat trick so you
can't quite do that but the reason why I
wasn't that Keen on wasn't that sure
about it was because um
after Pawn takes porn
out of the pawns are traded I was wasn't
sure about uh moves that add pressure so
D5 would be one of them Rook C4 would be
another kind of move
okay ah Knight D6 I'll tell you what
I'll play Knight D6 against D5 as well
to secure the Rook
uh-huh yeah yeah we we know that these
super Grand Masters and Grand Masters in
general love to over protect their
forces 96 attacking the queen and the
root no that's the most not the most
important thing it's offensive required
[Laughter]
um
yeah B5
I mean maybe you can just sit there on
Rick before and
say yeah that's good
life is good I've got this massive hole
on C5
and perhaps black and maneuvering
finagle is way over to C4 block is an
outpost too to how about them apples
and this gets very complicated
yeah it does gosh
not easy not easy at all I mean I found
them very deceptive and one of the
things that I find is that in the middle
game and the opening you burn so much
time every move will kind of cost 10
minutes on the clock just because
it's very difficult to kind of figure
out how you're going to neutralize each
each side's initiative what you're
you've got to find out what your
objectives are and yeah I mean is there
I mean uh 96 blade hey I like this move
as well it's
it's consolidating everything and
again he's just saying kick the queen
back
and
but then after after that what is black
gonna do then ah
but you can play 95 look pleadingly up
at your opponent repetition please but I
think it's more likely that he
establishes his Knight on B5 because
that's a much safer Outpost why because
when you look at an outpost it's
important to look at the quality of the
pawn that defends that Outpost
um and the A6 Pawn is totally
unassailable but the E6 spawn as you
mentioned right at the outset uh can be
forced off the board or at least Force
out of E6 by the move D5 and that is
called undermining so the Knight on B5
is a lot harder to undermine I think
that's what Lavon is aiming for there is
a repetition possibility Queen can come
back the Knight moves to B5 Queen comes
back to E4 but something tells me ding
is going to try to squeeze more out of
this position than just a colorless draw
yeah
I'm not so sure
I would be feeling nervous here but I
agree I mean ding is
a great player I mean he's bold I mean
if we saw anything from his previous
games we saw that he's so Fearless
he chooses this sharp openings and and
uh enters these roller coaster positions
he's completely unafraid and it's good
testing ground of course he has a big
match coming up in April world
championship match
and uh yeah every game will be worth a
weight in gold when it comes to training
so I mean good
that's going to be such an exciting
match but I just wanted to Echo your
point about fearlessness ding has a
solid style but solid should not be
confused for for cowardly I just
remember a game yet against Richard
report and the candidates in Madrid
where they had a wild position for 25
moves then he came to the press
conference uh to the interview and he
was telling Robert and I just the lines
he was calculating and just that the
cold-blooded nature with which he was
calculating a position where his King is
like on D6 and surrounded by enemy
forces it honestly made a big impression
on both of us I still kind of remember
it it was it was awesome to watch so
totally agree with your assessment of
ding
yeah I have to say my favorite press
conference with ding involved him in his
match against kramnik I can't remember
where but I remember but kramnik was in
his very confident stage where he was
just saying this is winning this is and
doing was just sitting there calmly and
just saying what about this move what
about that movie
I love that press conference
comedy gold is fantastic yeah
it definitely was ding is great I mean
he's he's much loved and for very good
reason well we love ourselves an
occasional break and we are going to
take one but before we do that an
important announcement because after two
years the wait is over and the pro chess
league is back the 2023 season begins
the qualifier week starting February 1st
with 16 teams advancing into the main
season past PCL participants include
Magnus ding speaking of nepo Fabi of
course Hikaru
lagrav annanesh Geary and many many more
so we could not be more excited for the
League's return and with over 100k on
the line it's looking like the 2023
season will be one for the history books
use x Glam PCL exclamation mark PCL in
the chat to learn all about it you will
not want to miss this new season of the
PCL and you will not want to miss more
action from the 85th Tata steel chest
turn tournament round six is ongoing we
are entering the third hour of games and
we will have more Tata Steel action for
you on the other side of this short
break
struggling to improve your game
chessable is the home for chess
improvers with hundreds of courses by
incredible authors like world champion
Magnus Carlson Christoph selecki andras
Toth everyone's favorite social media
troll known as Anish giri and so many
more chessable can help you raise your
game to the next level you're getting
started on the fundamentals you should
check out everyone's first chess
workbook
maybe you want to stop letting all those
points slip away in the end game 100 end
games you must know is the course for
you
maybe tactics are your weakness the
Woodpecker method has helped students
gain hundreds of Elo points
most importantly all of our courses are
powered by chessable's exclusive move
trainer technology which uses the
science of space repetition to make sure
it all sticks
check out chessable today and get 30
days of pro for free go to chessable.com
begin
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to round six of the Tata
steel chess tournament 2023. now vishy
Anand in our introductory interview
mentioned that Tata steel is the most
anticipated tournament every year it's
historic and it's not just a tournament
that's why everybody looks forward to it
it's not just a place where top GMS meet
to play chess it's also a festival as
you can see that beautiful playing Hall
and the open tournament that allows uh
normal regular amateur players to
participate in the fun and to catch
their own glimpse of their chess Idols
it has an 85 year history to be exact as
we have an overview there and the
conditions of the tournament are amazing
there's free parking the town of
waikansei is so picturesque it's just a
classic Dutch little village and and
there just isn't a better place to play
chessiovi yeah absolutely I mean just
the whole atmosphere of playing in a
village or a beach resort where everyone
is just thinking about Chess you go to
the restaurant and you bump into world
champion and I mean there's something so
special as well and also it really makes
my heart sing that after two years where
there's been a pandemic where we haven't
really been allowed to kind of be in
contact with other people that everyone
here and I mean just look at it it's
just bustling with people loving chess
concentration and
I cannot state that enough these are the
kind of tournaments that just make chess
wonderful amazing it connects us
together and this is what it's all about
it's all about like picking up those
pieces and just touching and pushing
wood
that's that's very well said Yogi and uh
I totally Echo that that sentiment and I
think in response to the idea that
classical chess is no place in OTB chess
has no place well I show I give you Tata
steel but you're right the atmosphere
has to be right you have to make it fun
for players of all levels in all ages
and the organizers of Tata steel have
succeeded in doing that year after year
after year it's entering its 85th year
and the excitement over the tournament
and over the field has not diminished
one bit in fact I think this is the most
exciting playing field in both the
Masters and The Challengers that we've
had in probably the last decade so what
a treat it is to be commentating this
85th Edition here we go back we are with
our bird's eye view we've got
developments on a lot of the boards
another exciting round I mean just like
yesterday we have such an Eclectic
assortment of different types of
positions we've got an end game in the
world champions game and in Wesley's
game we've got super complicated middle
games and fabby's game and reports I
mean whatever your heart desires
whatever you want to see you've got a
little bit of that and then some
yeah definitely
go ahead take your time well in the
meantime
I am going to try to quickly summarize
all of the positions as they currently
stand before we choose an actual game to
explore starting over on your top left
we have Wesley's game which we just
recently examined we called it Wesley
plays H4 and keeps the tension Vincent
kymer on camera nervously shuffling his
leg That's a classic chess player move
he is in an unpleasant position and he's
got a tall defensive task ahead of him
over to the right top right you've got
dingley Ren pushing a small advantage
against Levon bottom left you've got a
niche girian R generic I see a game that
just never seems to get any less sharp
there's just no Clarity on the board
even though pieces are getting traded
his last move Bishop G3 sets up the
devastating threat of E6 it's very clear
that Arjun is still very much on the
defensive yovi and speaking of on the
defensive pragnananda another tall task
as he tries to hold this Pawn down
position
yeah it's uh definitely a tough position
for the young Indian and uh the game
that I would really love to revisit is
one that we kind of thought was just
game over I mean we had dismissed it we
was like Fabi is just gonna win almost
in a few moves you know it's not going
to take him that long just to put the
boot in and uh just put a good cash out
of his misery but somehow the young
Indian player is still very much
surviving because it's not that easy now
if I'm looking at it you know yes black
king is open but there's no Harmony in
the White's forces I mean there's no
Clear Point to attack
and this does mean that the game will be
going on for a longer time and there is
chances for the cash to hold on
and I think the the two I think that was
very well said the two main chances
first of all are fabi's clock which is
down to 24 minutes Google cash really
does want to get this into a Time
scramble and the second is the queen
side play that he's been able to whip up
against the C4 Pawn I'm thinking of
Moves Like B5 there are some tactical
ideas like Knight to D5 or Knight to F5
so he needs to keep his pieces active as
for why this is more complicated than we
thought it would be I think the reason
consists in fabi's 19th move after Rook
F5 let's rewind a little bit
um and and see how we got here we talked
about them if Queen back to A1 get the
queen all the way back instead he goes
Queen C3 and after 97 that Queen
actually is a lot more vulnerable on C3
than it would have been on a one maybe
Fabi underappreciated the power of Rook
to H4 he ends up taking on C4
immediately and clearly this is the
worst version because he damages his
Queen Side Pawn structure now position
is still winning I'm positive and I
really like to move Rook to H4 but
kukesh can keep on fighting no doubt
about it maybe with a move like E5 maybe
he wants to tuck his King away on h8
but he still needs a miracle yobi but he
needs a slightly more minor miracle than
he would have needed if Fabi played
Queen A1
yeah and I also just kind of wanted to
touch upon the psychology of things
because one thing that he can also feel
hopeful about is the fact that Carolina
might start feeling a little bit
frustrated because bearing in mind that
everything was so easy beforehand now
yes the position is still winning but
it's not as clear I mean he Fabi has to
kind of go back to the drawing board and
find new ways to kind of just keep on
maximizing the potential in his position
um and I like your idea of just going E5
or King h8 just keep surviving on a move
by move basis and just play on the fact
that Fabi as the game draws longer and
longer he will be feeling some something
of frustration you know that he hasn't
finished the game already
very much so and to piggyback off of
that point on on the subject of the
psychology of Defending lost positions
one of my favorite chess authors of the
Scottish Grandmaster Jonathan Rosen as
E5 is indeed right on the board that was
the top move uh blunting the queen he
talks about what he calls goalkeeper's
glory and this is the idea that a
goalkeeper in soccer doesn't usually
score any goals throughout his career
how does he keep himself motivated well
the idea is you motivate yourself by the
thought that you're preventing the
opponent from scoring goals and he
advises the defender in a chess game to
adopt a similar mindset where you know
that you're not going to be better in
the next 50 moves you know that unless
your opponent blunders something you're
not going to win the game but what you
can take pride in is on every move
making it as difficult as possible for
your opponent to score a goal you just
keep reminding yourself that as
frustrated as you might be at how bad
the position is if you can keep the
evaluation steady then your opponent is
likely to be even more frustrated I
think kukesh is doing just that and I
think his position ain't looking all
that bad anymore
yeah I mean it's like you say it's we
have to remind ourselves it's still lost
you know he's still upon down he still
has a dreadful King but you know it's
not that easy for Fabi to find
constructive ways and the more that uh
could cash clings on does not blunder
and uses his time wisely because they're
now reaching that critical time where
you know when time travel starts to hit
then the the margin for error starts to
increase so 26 moves 26 minutes left
still the clock is ticking people feel
the pressure somewhat
mm-hmm
they most certainly do lukesh most
certainly will but Fabi he's down four
minutes he's taking his time and we will
keep a close eye as he attempts to score
a very important Victory here uh as we
reach the Midway point of this Marathon
event I mean 13 Rounds the OB I've never
played a 13 round tournament the most
I've played is 11 rounds of world youth
chess championships are typically 11
rounds in the U.S championship at least
in the last few years has been 11 rounds
and that feels like a marathon I can't
even imagine playing a 13 round event
honestly yeah 13 Rounds and I think this
is uh fabi's 13th appearance as well so
13 is his lucky number on the subject of
whether I've played 13 Rounds uh yes I
have I'm old enough to have done that an
olympiads
um but but but but
um and I think there used to be 16
rounds in the Olympiad and I
I didn't do that one but uh I did play
in that famous Alyssa Olympiad where we
started uh three days late because the
tournament venue was not ready
oh my gosh
yeah
that was 13 Rounds Classics and the
world junior as well used to be 13
Rounds and that was kind of annoying
because I remember I was leading the
tournament around 11 I was like if only
the tournament had finished it only had
been normal like every other tournament
on the planet but no
um move 30 round 13 came and I lost my
last game and I finished with a bronze
medal as opposed to my gold
heartbreaking well
given that this is gukesha's first
appearance at vikon say this is likely
to be his first 13 round event and
speaking of olympiads he played in the
last Olympiad in his home country
starting with eight out of eight that is
a performance that honestly is not
talked about enough and that rivals in a
certain sense Fabiano caruanas historic
start to the 2014 sink-filled cup where
I believe he started seven out of seven
now he started seven out of seven
against the slightly stronger field but
I think ukesh played six or seven Grand
Masters out of the eight games that he
won so a very bright future ahead of him
but just to to tie off the point we were
making about 13 Rounds it is a marathon
and I think the longer tournament is
obviously good for players who have a
very bad who are prone to slow starts
um and and prone to fast finishes and
there are players like that my good
friend GM Sam Shanklin is a great
example former US champion he almost
post always starts off with a couple
draws sometimes he has a loss but he's
an excellent physical shape and he
almost invariably wins uh the last round
and generally finishes very strong so I
think that's what Magnus Carlson has to
look for for inspiration as does gukesh
yeah and I'm glad that you mentioned
Magnus Carlsen because I wondered
whether we could take a whiz over to
that game because I know it's just an
end game
but I do feel that things are heating up
because take a look at Black's King and
take a look at what white has done with
his pawns on the king side because
um I remember being taught as a
youngster or rather shown at this uh
particular Pawn structure with the
triangle and my father would say to me
this is the worst type of Pawn structure
there is but then excesso never put your
pawns like that in that triangle
formation and I was like yes yes Dad yes
Dad I will never do that and I have this
I hope he's not watching but I didn't
really pay too much attention to many of
the other things he was saying but I did
you know that one did stick in my mind
and uh there you go the black king is uh
making a dash for those weak horns and
the reason I have to say that they're so
bad is because they can be restrained by
two pawns and this was the whole point
if two can restrain three then this is
just simple maths and it just means that
you have an advantage on that side of
the board
very well said and Magnus Carlson he
just he just always is going to find a
way to make things complicated it
doesn't matter what the commentators say
it doesn't matter how draw is
objectively it's just never going to be
as easy as just making a couple of moves
and Magnus offers you a draw I've only
experienced this in Blitz and that was
already enough for me to see how insane
the guy is at finding chances it's
uncanny you think it's in the bag
there's no possible way even if I give
him five moves in a row that he's gonna
create chances and yet he doesn't have
five moves in a row but he does manage
to create chances let's try to assess
whether white has actually messed up and
whether Black's winning chances are
realistic given accurate defense Rook to
C7 by Jordan who's got 17 minutes enough
time to make four more moves
and how is Magnus going to respond to
the threat of F7 let me just clarify one
more thing this is a three result game
if Magnus overpresses this is a
dangerous Pawn even though it will be
blockaded by the bishop so are we gonna
see a rook f8 or are we gonna see the
aggressive King to G3
yeah I'm really not sure what's
happening here because I can see even
moves like okay and uh this one might
surprise you or it might not it might be
totally bad or might be quite good
Bishop D5 was something that I was
thinking about with the idea that uh if
you do capture the pawn on F7 then the
king naturally goes to G3 and uh if
after Bishop takes Bishop Rick takes
bishop and then the whole point is once
it advances you get behind the passport
and uh you go Pawn hunting and that Rook
is a multi-functional
and uh the big problem with that
triangle formation is that once the king
nabs the G2 Pawn they all drop off like
flies
they do and the more concerning Pawn is
H3 once that pawn drops off black gets
his first pass pawn and probably not his
last pass Pawn so how can white try to
hold on here well one idea is to play
Rook to G7 King takes H3 and grovel with
Rook takes G5 but you can see the Evo
bar complaining after Rook takes A7 it's
lost the white king is just too far away
from the center of action black is just
gonna pick off the remaining Pawn with
Rick F7 takes F3 and again White's King
isn't even close to where it needs to be
for white to have realistic drawing
chances that means that I suppose in
this position white has to play some
sort of alternate defensive move maybe
you have to inch your king up all the
way to B6 as slow as that looks black is
impeded by one important tactical
feature which is that you cannot move
your king to the G file because now Rook
G5 comes with check deflecting black
stroke and then it's black who has to
grovel for a draw so maybe there's a way
around this maybe black can play E5
maybe even G4 G4 consideration in fact I
think it's the best move
and here you get a total
wow again
what does Yasser call it a John
I've forgotten this he has an expression
which I didn't know what it meant and
only Yasser uses it John Dory or
something like that John don't worry is
it a name yeah he uses a name and I
wasn't really quite sure anyway he'll
come to me or I'll Google it it's uh it
just means like a real brawl
Anything Can Happen brouhaha brawl no
I'm now I'm curious because I'll because
I'll definitely steal it but it'll come
to it'll come to you yeah yeah um let's
go back to lifeboard because we went
pretty far there but again Yobe I like
Bishop D5 and I think if he plays it and
by the way you can also play King G3
Rook takes F7 and then Bishop D5
probably same position we are almost
guaranteed to get that exact end game
and if Magnus finds G4 in that final
position man oh man are we in for a barn
burner of an end game
uh it's just gonna be uh it means so
much risk I mean it looks pretty
harmless and especially because the
evaluation bar just sits there on 0.00
likes to draw but in Practical terms
yeah the path is going to be Rocky for
both sides um of course white has as a
trump this past a pawn and if you don't
take good care of that you don't keep
that one on the lock and key then it'll
be white winning but uh of course the
black king very active white king far
away and I do feel that the danger is
more with Jordan he has to find the
correct path
no question about it and what's
terrifying is just the amount of time on
the world champions clock you talk about
his endgame prowess in Blitz and Rapid
games when the guy has over an hour and
he will have over an hour and move 40 is
made
you know he he can basically calculate
this out until the very end so Jordan's
immediate goal right now is to make sure
he doesn't make any blunders make move
40 and then force yourself to be as
patient as you can be try to calculate
this out until the very end and make
sure that you don't give Magnus any
unnecessary chances so fascinating end
game and this is going to reach an even
more fascinating climax we are going to
keep you posted on the world champions
efforts to score eight what would be a
very big comeback Victory think about it
if he wins this game with black he wins
tomorrow with white you'll be on plus
one it sounds crazy but that's how chess
sets how math works
yeah that's uh he will be on plus one
and there's no doubt about it I just
took a peek at the computer's
recommendation and actually the
recommendation is basically trade-off
Bishops so what we thought is going to
happen is
probably going to be on the board
anytime now
indeed and uh wow okay
yeah definitely and uh who else can we
take a look at
are we going to see can I just
quickly pop in
um are we going to see a repetition
when it comes to Livonia Ronin and ding
have they repeated moves they have
oh interesting you see that knight from
F7 to D6 back to F7
yeah I don't know what do you think
I don't know
the Knight comes back and if the Rook
comes back to E5 then we're gonna see
a draw
of their very first result
let's dig in and try to predict if we
think ding is gonna accede to the
repetition now the one counter argument
is of course the time situation 26 moves
only have been played and Lavon down to
15 minutes but we're not talking here
these players they never make decisions
only on the basis of the opponent's
clock ding isn't going to do something
foolish because he knows I'm good of a
blitz player Lavon is
now the big question are there
alternatives to rookie five I guess
there are right there's work F4
what do we make of that move
um
it kind of feels weird
because uh yeah attacks the queen but at
the same time
it kind of moves away from attacking the
Target on E6
so that once the queen moves and I'm
probably putting yeah probably in a G5
then that way she can swing over to B5
One Fine Day
um
yeah so
hmm yeah it kind of feels like you know
you're just contorting yourself a little
bit too much just to keep the game alive
um maybe you can go here and go after
the G7 Pawn which sounds crazy
and different new ideas if I just I mean
if I get Queen F6 I'm asking too much I
mean will you will this be the red rag
to the ball and you're gonna spring into
the position and attack me yes you are
yeah this is what I'm thinking but what
you bring up is the idea that the queen
could move perhaps onto a safer Square
B5 and what I missed is that after crook
before black just snaps off the pawn on
A5 and by the time white creates chances
on the king side Rook F4 by the way has
been played so there's our answer
and queen G5 and Rook back to G4
not back to G4 it came from E4 oh this
position is on the board it is on the
board planning against Queen B5
well the universe is telling you Dania
to buy a lottery ticket
everything today all right I'll be back
I'll be back in about an hour
of the commentary I trust
and and the quick question is okay Queen
B5 I like that move exactly Rook do
everything with tempo
yeah attack The Rook pin the Knight also
very important because you take the
sting out of Knight F4
so after Queen B5 I would imagine that
Ding will just move back to A1
and then things really sharpen up black
and plant the Knight on F5
totally three result game here I mean
this could get very chaotic with the
players posturing for position in the
center Queen B5 on the board Levon
playing quickly and confidently
I don't know if ding's position inspires
me with confidence even though the eval
bar is indicating a significant Edge
Queen C2 that's what he had in his
pocket that's what he got in his pocket
oh nice move you know no going backwards
for doing instead the whole idea is just
to renew the threat of Knight F4 and uh
once that diagonal clears and the queen
is uh
just putting herself on G6 and I of
course
there's a pawn up for graphs on the
board I did not spot that one I was so
busy looking on the diagonal and I did
not see the most Elementary thing
that is standard fare for me in my OTB
games so just a position in which both
sides armies are simultaneously active
and also like stock and molasses where
you've got so many weaknesses to keep
tabs on that you have to tread very
lightly here I am expecting Knight to F5
then maybe white plays Rook before so
the position heating up and uh this game
is a very high probability of uh ending
in some sort of a Time scramble as the
players have over 10 moves to make and
not a lot of time to do it but there's
another game which is likely to end in A
Time scramble and that is a niche giri's
battle against Arjun arag icy we flip on
bird's eye view for a moment here by the
way Magnus Carlson look at us Bishop D5
on the board
and uh he's gonna try to push that end
game a trade in notorbeck's end game as
well which we also thought was a
possibility
oh okay uh shall we go to noripex and
game uh here he's off to rule tournament
leader four points out of five which is
an incredible score having defeated
Magnus Carlson with the black pieces
yesterday in round
five sure let's take a quick look at
that end game and then we'll look at the
other leader uh well the second in
command Anish Gary whose position also
percolating well I wonder what white is
going to do here because I mean really a
case should be made for not recapturing
the queen and playing H4 to improve the
pawn structure
I mean
um he's gonna take back on D3 and the
real question is does White have any
realistic winning chances because
correct me if I'm wrong
it doesn't seem to me that objectively
we could talk about white being winning
this is with 100 certainty a draw
objectively but can white create
practical chances where do you stand on
that question
um I certainly think that white will be
able to create practical chances because
my understanding is that even
with if the knights were to be traded
this four versus three although
technically a draw is still not without
its dangers so if that's the case then
if you throw in a knight set of nights
on the board then okay
then white has a chance to do things
like for instance you can visualize a
position where the white knight ends up
on F6 I know this is a pipe dream for
the time being you know white
establishes this beautiful Pawn chain
you know one's an F4 G4 G5 and yeah
black will be in big trouble if this all
happens so
black can't just sit there and pass on
every move he has to also come up with
some kind of plan himself and it could
be simply just uh sitting on the second
sorry seventh row with his Rook or maybe
just expanding a little bit on
the king side with H5 just to kind of
stop white from advancing any of his
Pawns
I I think H5 is worth tossing in just as
a as a thoughtless move now it's always
important to establish who benefits in
the event of both trades if the knights
are off so Pawn end games are mostly
going to be winning for White Knight end
games are also not very pleasant for
black the common wisdom goes that night
end games are the most similar to Planet
games so I think the most desirable
trade for black is a trade of knights
which would reach a very well-known kind
of four on three Rook end game and we've
seen even GMS lose the four on three
with pawns on the same side of the board
if you're in time pressure there's a lot
of ways uh to whip up some play and uh
we've seen blunders Galore but I think
Prague should be able to hold it
especially if he has the ideal Pawn
structure with the pawn diagonal from F7
to H5
so I agree with your approach I think
you play H5 you basically sit on the
seventh rank you don't do anything
extraordinary you watch for tactics and
you wait for an opportunity to trade the
knights should be a trouble I think I
think it should be a draw and I fully
expect Pride to draw but it will not be
the easiest path to a draw I mean you
will have to work hard and uh
well that's okay and these are very
talented
so he's I don't know maybe
it sounds very familiar but I can't
quite Place well that's Genera that's a
more generic you know Soviet GM but the
well I remember when I play this
position I already had two seconds after
five moves I still managed to save as a
game so I've got the generic Russian GM
and then the you know the grishooks of
the world that's who it was I was like
it sounds very much like girl found but
it wasn't quite girl found on Earth okay
yes
yeah I'll roll that out you know at an
appropriate moment G5 by by Prague which
is also very sensible by the way because
you're preventing white from playing F4
and you're using you're squeezing the
juice out of your night placement so
he's going to play G5 and H6 and we're
gonna keep an eye on this game as
noderbeck tries to squeeze out another
but will be very very difficult win well
he beat Magnus in an end game yesterday
can he go to for two back we are in the
bird's eye view by the way Jordan's game
against Magnus is hurtling toward the
position we were looking at with A6 on
the board but the game I really want to
go to now is anisha's Anish giri's
bloodbath against Arjun Eric icy
shall we make a trip to garyland
absolutely yes and uh what is happening
here I mean it just looks terrible for
Eric icy and things are not going his
way I mean
it's creaking at the seams look at all
those open lines I mean first of all
there's a pawn up for grabs and if the
queen Falls I mean there's also I also
really like moves like E6 unleashing the
dragon there on G3 I've been itching to
play E6 for
quite a while now and my in well my I'm
not known for my patients let's put it
this way that makes two of us no I think
E6 is a great move and and Black's
resource that likes defense is just
strained to the Limit what is Arjun
planning against E6 exactly I think it
might be Rook to be too
but you see the email bar creeping up
Queen takes C5 is not out of the
question but I actually don't like this
move as much because after trade and C3
suddenly black gets a massive counter
play right C2 Rook B1 comes really fast
and you can't take the Knight so what I
like instead
is the move Queen to A5 just squeeze the
queen into a beautiful square right in
Black's Grill
attacking the Knight Knight can't move
Rook probably has to move back to B4
this is yucky yeah and white can
continue
yes yes
or Knight D4 by the way maybe even
better is to play this move Knight to D4
to control the B5 Square
takes takes hanging hanging hanging
hanging this is over
[Laughter]
exactly that's the tip of the iceberg
there's a mate thread on B8 also
yeah oh my goodness me no that's this is
this is bad news Okay
um
oh
now this is not the end of the story
because takes takes black can take and
say oh well I've restored material
balance hey E7 hey you're gonna have a
problem yeah no no no this is oh wine
okay fine now East can you resist D6
because I can I would not nothing would
make me not go E6 there it's just too
tempting
no I mean the lines that we've shown or
you've shown are just incredible for
white
um so E6 what is Black's best move I
mean I don't think you can go Rook B2
that'll probably lose on the spot so you
have to do something else
like see anything
C3 yeah why not
Roblox
got to be pushed yeah they do
but I can slide my queen into C2 and
maybe Arjun wants some sort of defensive
construction I think the move Rook
before is involved in one way or another
so Queen C2 Rook B4 and E6 Pawn suddenly
starts feeling just a little bit
uncomfortable so maybe it's worth
playing a more solid move like Queen E2
to protect the pawn and also aim at A6
nah I mean this has to be lost but in
the complications and in the time
pressure anything can happen so I would
take this evaluation with a grain of
salt
yeah absolutely and this position is
fire on the board but somewhere else
where things are shaping up in a very
dramatic fashion uh is in the Fabiana
harijuana game because
if Fabi plays E4 then apparently the
game will be just over
be dead done and dusted
wow well we know what that means a lot
of the other games have reached some
clarity but they are far from over we
need to get to Fabiano's Game King to F7
was the final move and okay so E4 why
does it end the game no no actually I've
just checked it so C5 is a killer move
C5 is the gonna move H6 is another move
E4 is also another move yes
but okay so let's let's pull up an
announcement here so C5 Rook takes C5
what's the killer oh and now age six H6
he's played it immediately so let's
rewind for a second H6 is on the board
threatening Rook G7 Gucci is probably
gonna go Knight G6 he has to go Knight
G6 there's uh nothing for it oh and now
you go
Queen D7 wins the game
Bishop Audrey also wins the game
as does C5 to deflect The Rook off of A5
and then you go well basically just to
show why Queen D7 is so strong because
it might be counterintuitive to trade
Queens the point is that because H7 is
so weak black has to swing back to G8
and C5 here is devastating Rook takes C5
and the point of the move C5 is actually
to play this mysterious look Rook move
Rook to C4
you think about why does this work
because after the trade which is
basically forced being h8 Rook I said
just look at this position the Knight is
totally restricted black is down a pawn
he's about to lose another one and the
king is never getting out of h8 so this
is the computer line but even if Abby
does not find C5 the game is still over
I mean there is no way that gukesh holds
this together
is there I mean it's just falling apart
you can't live without a Pawn on H6 and
uh just look at Black's pieces no no no
no they're just clowns they're not
attacking forces at all no it's just
dead in the water
um
yeah difficult to come up with the move
and I just love the move uh Bishop F3
also looks really good you know yeah
threading the bishop to T5 I mean that
looks quite irresistible
what else is there uh Queen D7 looks
brutal
C5 looked like an artist's move
I don't seven minutes though he's got to
make a decision I mean the last thing
Fabi wants is to bring himself down to a
minute because we know anything can
happen in a Time scramble
and that bears repeating so I think
fabby's gonna go Queen D7 I think given
the time situation
uh you know a risk-free option that
lends more clarity to the position is is
what he wants but if he goes Queen E7 he
really needs to find C5 after the trade
because otherwise he's gonna lose the A3
Pawn you don't want to give black
counter play in the form of a past
Corner Pawn
yeah
and uh how How likely is he to find this
I mean
we're kind of just looking at the
evaluation bar and kind of
just judging on that saying it's easy
but I mean in a real kind of tournament
scenario you're the one facing
good cash you don't have access to the
engine you have no idea what it's saying
you kind of feel that it should be
winning
but will there be any stress I'm just
taking a look at the times and uh six
and a half minutes 28 moves played hmm
yeah I mean Abby's a much improved Blitz
player but
you know you you wanna you wanna give
yourself a little bit of cushion here C5
is very easy to see conceptually because
the queen and the King are aligned and
you know you want to put the bishop on
this diagonal what's hard about it is
you see Rook takes C5 you're like well
darn I can't go Bishop C4 and then it's
easy just to reject the line because the
primary idea doesn't seem to work but
there's the secondary idea of C5 which
is the C4 Square isn't just good for the
bishop it's also good for The Rook to
get rid of Black's only active piece so
C5 in a weird way is actually a very
positional idea you're trading off your
opponent's only active piece in the end
game
I'd be down to six minutes now decision
is coming soon
yeah and I was also wondering the
scenario like how you know how fine is
the path that he has to take because I'm
just thinking if he just plays a normal
move like for instance and prepare C5
like puts the queen on B4 you know
and how's the not so not so subtle
threat of playing C5 lining up Bishop C4
I mean is that also gonna be winning or
I mean will questions be asked about the
white Rook um
G4 so I'm thinking F5 could be in the
air that's the move that I would play If
I were black
yeah you know it is winning for sure I
think Bishop after your move is winning
but their white uh black drags the king
over to E7 and somehow like the squares
on the D file are going to be protected
Queen B4 can be met with the annoying
move Rook to C5 kind of shutting the
door on the diagonal so the one way you
see even top players screwing up totally
winning positions is when they they burn
all of their time trying to find a force
to win they realized toward the end that
the forced wind doesn't exist or there's
something wrong with the line that they
were calculating and then impulsively
they you know they make a mistake on the
basis of nerves and emotions and at that
point they have a minute on the clock
for 10 moves and anything can happen in
that scenario if I'd be down to four and
a half minutes we keep talking he keeps
thinking
well he has to keep thinking because
this is a critical moment because it's
crunch time here if he finds the correct
solution then he can just Blitz out the
next few moves and win the game mm-hmm
so I I do think that is advisable to
burn some time on the clock but uh not
if you don't see anything
I mean I I think if you spot C5 and then
you're trying to make it work great
yeah I may I I don't know actually I'm
thinking that I'm being quite specific
to the position as a general rule I
would probably
you know I have this kind of phrase you
know you're in a monopoly you know you
just want to bank it and maybe I would
be going Queen D7 just put it in the
bank I don't care get that great
position I don't care if the computer
doesn't approve and gives it plus one
plus two there you kind of know that
it's just two results
um things can't go wrong
yeah wow lands what a move C5 on the
board and that must mean he understood
the underlying idea he's not just hoping
that gukesh takes with the pawn or
something he understands that he will
take with the Rook that is just that is
vintage Fabiano you called it earlier
Yogi he just he takes the time that it
takes whatever it takes to calculate
everything out like the machine that he
is
yeah absolutely and uh such a beautiful
move I have to say I have a special
place in my heart for these types of
moves and I just love it when they just
give up horns
in a square that it looks like is
impossible to advance to and it's all to
do with opening up the diagonal opening
up those lines and a rook takes C5 on
the board and then the question of Queen
D7 so quick
immediately and he's going to execute
the sequence at this point it's it's
basically decided Rook takes
and at that point you don't even you
don't have to play Rook C4 in response
to King Juliette but I think if you've
seen C5 then it's very likely that he's
also seen Rook C4 Bishop to D3 by the
way uh is is a very solid alternative
just going after the night so he's
totally winning now I hate to jump the
gun here yo but there's two more games
that are going completely haywire and I
want to make sure we're keeping tabs on
them I think we can entrust the winning
process to Fabiana here he's done the
hard work now he has the easy work left
so we're looking at our bird's eye view
the Wesley game
is wild
and the Anish game as well and look at
magnus's position this is exactly what
we had in our analysis and this is where
we were discussing the move G5 to G4 in
order to sacrifice the pawn and create
some shelter for the King on the G file
isn't that awesome
that that is awesome I I love that and
uh shall we head over to these Wild
games
um maybe we will take a quick peek at
Wesley uh against Vincent because just
looking at Pawn structure something
looks a bit suspicious I mean wow I mean
we thought that the pressure was all
um on Wesley you know he was just making
those right moves and now I see a black
porn on A4 and I'm terrified that Mark
is going to be able to create something
magical there on the queen side
well it appears that Wesley messed up I
don't think he's messed up to the point
where it's he's losing I just think this
is going to be a draw to rewind back to
where he played H4 Vincent plays G6
forces the queen back and queen back to
Seagate so he did find all of the Right
Moves perhaps not in the most accurate
move order
he sacrifices the pawn everything is
traded and Bishop takes H6 happens but
look at Black's Pawn majority on the
queen side he's got a three on two he's
got the terrifying potential of creating
a past Pawn that could decide the game
instantly Wesley tries to dry it up with
B3 but that creates a hole on A3 that
Vincent immediately occupies C4 is met
with A4 undermining the B3 pawn and
Wesley responds for the ultracom G3
looks like absolute Brazen nonsense
after 86b3 but the Knight drops back to
D2 and this I think is how Wesley is
going to hold the draw a b Knight D2
then white takes on B3 and
simultaneously attacks the pawn on C5 so
we are going to get something like a
takes B3 Knight to D2
black can even play a move like F6 to
get rid of the pawn you were gonna say
Bishop B7
it should be seven yeah
you know hold on
I like it
yeah and like neither side can make Pro
I mean white could try to expand on the
king side
um but the problem is that Wesley can
never really take on B3 because this
gives black connected passwords here
black is actually winning
so we're gonna get a standoff of this
Sword and the question really is going
to be can white make something of his
Pawn majority on the king side and can
white keep the situation stable on the
other side of the board this has to be a
draw I have no doubt about it
um and I think black's got enough time
to make it
yeah that's uh oh complicated ending
there and it is I mean a completely
unexpected unbalanced and uh providing
us a lot of entertainment and uh can we
just Dash over to the Magnus against
Jordan game because uh we kind of called
it but now they're actually in it and
yeah they are exactly that position and
we're here we kind of we came to the
conclusion that the very flashy move G4
was a nice try to do something
it's a nice try and it might be really
the only try
uh because okay so there's two ways that
black can prepare actually three ways
that black and prepare the move King G3
the first is to move the Rook away from
A5 and let's just illustrate to
everybody so we're on the same page why
does this not work because Rook takes G5
is a classic deflection white promotes
this still should be a draw but
obviously not the way that Magnus wants
to make it the first way is to move the
Rook away from A5 so that Rook takes you
five doesn't deflect The Rook the second
is our initial idea G4 and the third is
actually this move E5 which puts uh some
distance between the two Rooks I like
the look of E5 and it's actually hard to
evaluate this resulting position it
should be a draw according to the engine
but man I'd be terrified of going for
this against Magnus
yeah I do think that that feels like a
draw primarily because the white king is
very close to the black kings and it is
an H Pawn and those pawns are not that
great I have to say when it comes to
getting them promoted
um yeah one other thing that I I was
kind of considering was
um
yeah moving The Rook away that was
something that I had in mind
just move and then after Rook takes Pawn
you capture but
again white can just take here and then
inch the king closer
yeah and normally the technique for
freeing your own thing is to give a
check
and then go Rook A2 to G2 but the
problem is that this E6 spawn can be
directly targeted and black just isn't
fast enough I mean kg3 you can go back
to G5 or you can even take on E6 and
there's always going to be this super
nasty check to force the king in front
of the pawn and even without the F Pawn
at this point this is a draw with the F
fun we're not even you know discussing
any winning chances so Jordan I think is
going to be very close to holding this
game but he's got to realize that it's
okay to sacrifice the a pawn for the
g-pod yeah and I think a player of
Jordan's caliber will of course see that
no problems and then finally we have to
look at the G4 line that we
we were looking at and G4 I guess
presumably if you don't want to run the
risk you simply capture with a rook and
we have the same scenario as we did
before no need to get into any
complications the G4 on the board
that's Magnus Carlson playing the most
artistic move
every chance is going to be squeezed out
and the good thing about G4 in
comparison to the other two moves is
this actually gives Jordan a choice and
you might say well aren't choice is good
not always because even though well I
guess move 40 has been made so he's got
57 minutes to decide what he wants to
take with it appears that FG is also a
draw but I'm totally on the same page if
you see that Rook G4 is a draw you take
with the Rook you move your king back
at that point you basically sign the
score sheets there's just no way to make
progress
yeah thanks thanks oh
here
check
here here here here here
but you're in time to go kick F2 this is
the detail he has to spot otherwise
black wins with King G2 and H3
move
so neat
um I mean is it still so simple after
Rook H6
doesn't make the finest impression and I
would I would certainly say that the AFK
you got it in the bag and the key
fun if it was an eye file oh no
I managed to make it a loss for black oh
dear no no
still a drawer this is a hilarious
repetition anyways uh G4 is on the board
and Jordan presumably is going to spend
at least 15-20 minutes pondering which
way to take if he takes with a pawn the
game is going to get super interesting
again and we will re-examine it if he
takes the rook and moves his King back
essentially the result will have been
decided he has two moves away from
holding the world champion to a pretty
confident draw uh you'll be a result
that Magnus would normally be okay with
but in this case is merely going to add
uh to his frustration
yeah and uh Jordan in the tank thinking
and uh let's have a look at some of the
other wild games
um because we had a few
we left Anish Gary in a rather crazy
position and we thought it was nearly
all over for aragaisy and I'm just
taking a look at the position now and
I'm thinking no there's still a lot of
life left in the position in fact I
wouldn't necessarily say that an issue
is actually better
no I think Arjun is yet again just like
yesterday in a situation where he's
getting mated Seven Ways to Sunday finds
a ridiculous sequence to hold the
dragon's dengler and I think he's doing
something very similar I think he's
close to another miracle and yes I'm
gonna call this a miracle because his
position was just I mean staggeringly
difficult uh to defend we have to rewind
a little bit to where Geary played E6 as
we predicted Rook to B4 was the response
and here Knight to D4 centralizing the
night Queen moves back
and at Knight C2 and Arjun I'm checking
he's playing only moves he's playing the
top engine move on every move bang C3
counter-attack the queen Force the queen
trade
but the Rook gets to B2 black has the
Monster Pawn on C3 and just how do you
evaluate this position
it's impossible and here Gary makes a
mistake
oh okay apparently what is the mistake
is the mistake to capture the Knight
well he plays the human move to create
some Luft
yeah but apparently the best move was
King to F1
and here's the difference after Rook C2
Rook A4 Bishop F2 Bishop takes F2 is not
a check and white has time for this
intermed so whoop Rook F4
intercepting the mechanism and forcing
The Rook trade and essentially the pawn
on E6 should decide the game you
basically Force black to give the bishop
away for that pawn now compare contrast
compare this to the position currently
on the board after Rook C2 Rook A4
Bishop takes F2 is now a check and
what's gonna happen after Bishop F2 is
that white is forced to trade enabling
black to set up the Piggies on the
seventh and I think Arjun will have
enough counter play here to secure the
draw yeah how did Gary miss that so
simple no I have to say I completely
forgot that it was a back rank mate I
somehow assumed that the H porn had been
moved
and it hadn't I
it's unbelievable actually it feels like
Eric icing is living Nine Lives she's
like a cat
um
and I just like what he's done you know
the Rook G4 Rook is going to go to E2
and let's not forget as well that uh
black also has a past Pawn on C3 which
is going to start making a niche nervous
as well so I do think that this position
will bail out into a draw and meanwhile
we do have a result actually in one of
the games between Fabiana Carona and
gukash that ended in a victory for Fabi
and we saw him following the perfect
sequence of moves and uh just looking at
the final position we can see he's
played it
perfectly like a master
Exquisite technique by Fabi water went
honestly just such a nice confidence
booster let's quickly review the final
couple of moves and we can't slow down a
little bit
um we can slow down just a little bit
because most of the games have made move
40. okay Queen D7 check there was a
trade he took on A7 immediately which is
also good enough ukesh tries to get
active with his Rook yeah and then Rook
before takes B6 stick it on B7 talk
about Piggies on the seventh yeah and uh
incidentally we also have another result
uh Richard and Parham that ended in a
draw like both players were in a
fighting mood but they had a fighting
draw and that is all good
and we're capturing them on camera there
the final position just a three on three
with minor pieces on the board I look
through the game during the break this
was balanced all the way through this is
a good old school just balanced game
between two super GMS both of whom hate
draws but this is why chess works the
way it is both players play well a draw
is can be a fair result and you
shouldn't just look at the result and
say well this must have been a boring
game it wasn't it deserves to be
analyzed but it was balanced all the way
through we're two results in it's funny
how in chess in these tournaments you've
got results occurring at the same time a
lot of the time
and I really love seeing the players
analyze afterwards and you kind of feel
that uh Bond of kinmanship you know the
two players have played something
together they've created a special game
and uh yeah it was a very correct
results for the two players and uh
maxood Lou he will be on 50 and Richard
Rapport after his first round loss to
gakesh he is still minus one on the
scoreboard
indeedy is well we've got two results
ladies and gentlemen and we've got so
many more fascinating games on going
let's swing back to the bird's eye view
one game that hasn't changed like in a
while is that Ding aronian game so
they're still basically keeping the same
type of structure with a couple of games
have changed a lot I mean Prague I think
is still handsomely holding the draw
against Abdus tutorial I'm gonna guess
that that game doesn't last too much
longer Jordan has taken with the pawn he
has not taken to the Rook he's done the
more risky move oh my God that is going
to be just an epic finale to that game
and Geary actually has stepped away with
his King he has not taken the bishop on
F2 he doesn't want to permit black to
get Rooks on the seventh Rank and Rook
to D2 by Arjen and that game is getting
crazy we definitely have to go to where
the madness is because uh I mean just
look at this position you know
and both Kings open to the elements
uh it doesn't matter it is it's a draw
it's a dry it's going to liquidate so
it's important I think to just isolate
the factors here first of all
The Rook on D5 is hanging what else is
hanging well the bishop on F2 is
defended the bishop on G3 is defended A6
is also hanging with check but that's
not important because there's always
just King B7
so the move which throws even more oil
onto the fire is we bring up an analysis
board is E7
but black responds very calmly get rid
of the bishop
and slide The Rook simply over to E8 and
that's why you put the Rook on D2 so
that there's no Rook d8 check in this
position and I think White's got nothing
better than to basically
trade Rooks
and go takes here here here and it's
time to sign the score sheets even the
white king is nominally closer it
doesn't matter that's not going to be
enough to produce any chances
wow it is I agree and uh what a finale
though it's a such a Head Rush of a
gaming it's been a real roller coaster
but okay
I mean is there anything else E7 I love
that move and I also wanted to point out
one thing that after after E7 Rook E8
and when you kind of touched upon it
after Rook takes A6
I think that that would be a big mistake
because you go King to King B7 and then
the thing I wanted to mention that after
Rook takes Rook you do have um
Bishop takes bishop and you you don't
actually have to capture
yeah you mean instead of Rook takes A6
like if you hear take on yeah because
there's all sorts of checks captures
yeah Bishop takes Bishop first and yeah
you have so many things actually but
here actually white has the check on d8
so I think to your point it's important
to not procrastinate take on G3
immediately because rookie 8 Rook d8
actually forces black
to give away the bishop and black is
unable to promote white stops the pawn
from behind and here white should be
winning yeah so one more trap that Gary
can spring with the movie Seven I also
don't think he's got an alternative to
E7 I think otherwise he risks losing the
game so he's thinking but I think
largely right now he's convincing
himself that he's squandered an
opportunity but I would argue that this
game if it ends the way we think it will
is going to be less about Geary
frittering away a big advantage and more
about Arjun putting together yet another
stunning defensive display time pressure
wildly miserable position we King he
doesn't care the guy just weathers
whatever his incredibly strong opponents
throw at him and he does it with style
and with Grace and he's just so hard to
bring down it's crazy yeah I mean we've
seen it time and time again he's so
resourceful and he's willing to use the
dynamism of his pieces and his natural
talent and Flair for that style just to
save all of those lost points and I have
to say I've been very impressed and you
called it E7 on the board Bishop takes
Bishop Arjun precise until the very end
and the players are following that route
and we're probably going to see Rook
takes work
and I mean is there any chance to kind
of squeeze anything from that very level
end game I mean I could just see a
scenario where the white key kind of
snakes its way to G6
well the thing is you know Black's King
is pretty close itself King D7 LAX King
is going to be on the C file before you
know and black can actually use the Rook
trade as a bridge to advance the king to
the default I think a draw for is
forthcoming after Arjun takes on E7 and
Gary takes on D2 there we go
and so what I'm talking about here is
kc6 and then Rook to D7
and black makes it to fa just in time if
you get a pawn end game so
this is going to be a draw in just a
moment here it does really just offer
Eric icia draw because uh Eric I say in
his time
has actually left the board and he has
he's gone to Austin the Arbiter please
sir please sir can I take a drawer
no obviously you end this game
no no I feel like I could have come
across as mocking I was not mocking I
was just uh no it's funny it was just
funny when uh you have to ask the
Arbiter for permission
um
it's sometimes it gets a bit ridiculous
it really I mean and and again this is
about the spirit of the law you know
letter of the law kind of thing the
point of all this is to prevent short
uninteresting games these this game is
the opposite of what some of these quick
draws look like both players putting
everything on the line you know you've
got to let them agree to withdraw here
there's no point in playing this end
game out and uh I think as the players
look for an Arbiter and request
permission to uh end this game in a
peaceful manner we should probably swing
to magnus's game because that game is
heating up at Breakneck pace
wow uh indefinitely let's go there as
quick as we can and uh to me
it looks wild but I do feel that this
ultimately will be a draw it will be a
massive Pawn race
but it will probably finish King versus
King so Rook A1 okay The Rook has to
move is under attack and naturally you
want the maximum checking distance so
put it far away from the white king
and
yeah I'm just looking at the camera
looking at Magnus there yeah he looks
like he knows this is not going to end
the way he wants to look at him now now
he's kind of showing a little bit more
kind of like no come on Magnus every
single chance yeah exactly let's get
going one more push
snap two
um but after so here's my question after
Rook A1 which I think is likely now if
Magnus wants a draw he can take a seven
and then take G4 and that you know that
ends the game immediately
but let's say he goes for K1 white goes
King B5 no but this is just to draw H3
King B6 White's in time whites in time
to defend the pawn with the King
otherwise otherwise black would have
been able to take on A7
and at this point the g-pawn is going to
advance forward so black actually has no
choice but to start repeating moves
rugby one Rook A1 and we know the drill
yeah I think this is how the game is
going to end either this or Magnus is
going to take on A7 but I don't think
he's going to take longer than like 5-10
minutes because
as wild as this position looks and I was
hoping for something more exciting
this just liquidates very cleanly into a
draw yeah and so what about if he
doesn't I
think that fizzled out to a draw what
happens if Jordan decides to actually
push the g-pawn and say hey you've given
me something that I can push
consequences and immediately I saw the
evaluation bar shut up all the way down
so this is not a good idea by Jordan but
this is good to establish and uh now
Rick
yep and now you can take the pawn
it's not the end of the story I've got
G7 oh
oh my God there's a beautiful idea here
and I think it's the only move so two
things
H1 Queen saying let me distract The Rook
is bad for many reasons you can't even
take on G7 but more importantly white
can promote with check
but you can play Rook A8 and it looks
like white holds with rookie shade but
Rook to G8 is the only winning move what
a resource I don't know that this move
produces such a strong aesthetic effect
it wins and it's beautiful so there is
a way that Jordan can go wrong and he
has to actually step forward with his
King to support the a pawn and uh Magnus
um it looks like he's frustrated could
he just simply being like in calculation
mode I mean it looks like he's thinking
come on brain work your magic
or do you think he's just simply
everything I think
yeah I mean he knows already at this
point the evaluation he notices a dead
draw I honestly think he's just sort of
examining the situation in the
tournament I mean this is this is not
this wouldn't be in his nightmare the
fact that he's minus one after sixth
round it's the sort of General annoyance
that comes from having a tournament like
this and largely I think practically
he's deciding between okay one and Rook
takes A7 he knows both options lead to a
draw he knows there's no way Jordan will
play G5 even if Jordan you know didn't
see Rook A8 to G8 and that at the end of
that line
why risk it right if you're calculating
King B5 King B6 that is such a force
draw that there's literally there's just
nothing to calculate there so
I think Magnus is just coming to terms
with the reality of the situation yeah
it suddenly looks that way and uh only
really one try and that's to move the
Rook down to A1 just uh
make a move and Magnus shaking his head
um
and uh
should we stick with this game because
there is another game where the action
is brewing up quite nicely I mean
they're in some kind of time travel and
that's between dingleren and levonne
aronian
shall we head there yeah I think we
should because I I think as we look at
the bird's eye view I'll just point out
two things first of all Vincent kymer
has sort of well not sort of he's
seriously messed up and now stands in a
very alarming spot against Wesley so I
actually think Wesley now has serious
winning chances but I agree I'd like to
go to the ding game because the nature
of the position hasn't changed in a
while but the time has dwindled for both
players and we should definitely update
that important game so off we go to ding
aronian
two minutes to one minute for four
entire moves here we go
yeah I mean it's that kind of feels like
the game hasn't actually changed that
much I mean we've kind of been here
before
but still it's very very tense
and uh ding well ding has just under two
and a half minutes was Levon has just
over one and a half minutes before moves
and I mean it's not serious time trouble
but still there is room for error and uh
Dean playing the most accurate move you
know moving his Queen up stepping
forward over protecting the D4 Pawn
yep I agree yeah Queens Queen C3 I don't
know what I can predict the next kind of
moves you know Grand Master moves it'll
be like G3 when you're in time trouble I
heard that the big Golden Rule is just
don't make any committal moves so keep
everything protected keep your king
saved and then after the critical move
40 then you can go there and actually
lash out or plan out what you're gonna
do
yeah don't make it worse that's that's
the goal one minute for aronian uh it's
interesting ding declines several
repetitions in this late middle game I
can just read off aronian's last moves
and they were starting from move 31 this
is move 37 Queen F5 Queen G6 Queen F5
Queen G6 Queen G5 Queen B5 and finally
he's moved a different piece knight D6
to F5 on the last move here I like the
look of Rook to D5 kind of a similar
move in spirit and he's just played it
he's played it and he establishes The
Rook in the center and guess what I
don't think aronian is worse I think
ding might have been well advised to
take one of those repetitions because if
he's not careful aronians made some
serious improvements to his position in
the last couple moves yeah I I do agree
with you but it's also very difficult to
see how Lavon can continue with his
improvements I don't really see the
Breakthrough that's going to be
happening I mean if white just stands
still and just makes a random move like
G3 I just like that oh H5
no not that one because
that pawn on age five
it's breaking the time travel rules you
know you've got to keep everything
protected and that one is not important
to easily
protect basically because if the queen
goes back to E8 what are you gonna do
yeah
the queen goes back to E8 you might have
to go G4 well I think the pawn is a
double-edged sword because if you can go
G4 and then stick a knight on G6 that
creates the potential for the classic
sort of uh arabian-like mate on h8 so I
think an aronian's time pressure with
one two three more moves to make until
time control dig is actually using that
to his Advantage here and trying to stir
the pot
uh right before move 40.
yeah uh definitely but it carries risk
for both players actually because uh if
okay Rook D7 played so Levon is
following the rules you know he's kind
of not committing anything but then okay
The Rook on D7 is just asking why to
plant the Knight on E5
and perhaps ding should start with the
move G4 get the Knight off of F5 to open
the f file
and you're absolutely right I think
Lavon might have underestimated the
power of the Knight maneuver to G6 this
could get really unpleasant at the most
inopportune moment for Lavon
yeah
um absolutely and taking a look at the
time
and here comes
G4 on the board you I gotta step forward
with the Knight I mean if you signal the
retreat
it feels clumsy like 96 and you're just
losing connection it looks horrible and
Knight E7 again looks terrible because
the ideas that you kind of reference are
putting a knight on G no you don't want
to be doing that just go forth a knight
on H4 an H4
white oh he goes backwards does go back
to E7 but it it makes sense to me
actually I was gonna because you're
defending the G6 square and I think that
is your top priority right now as
unpleasant as it is to consign your
knight to this passive existence you
have to keep G6 under lock and key and
we're going to see 95 by ding I think
yeah or are we because 95 there's a
there's a sack on E5 followed by Rook D1
and queen F1 and that could actually be
incredibly dangerous for white so maybe
it's not worth for ding to play 95.
no I mean G4 has certainly come with
some risk and so has he played Rook F4
hmm
well yes I do maybe Rook to E4 makes
some sense targeting the E6 spawner old
friend that was the original idea of
ding's play or maybe Queenie one is also
in the air
step back with the queen and uh get her
in the middle of the action
C5 is the time control move or ding
oh my gosh can I tell you something
crazy Levon is 30 seconds to find the
move E5 which is actually the only way
to keep the balance so Ding and he found
it oh this is unbelievable this is such
a star so good I know so good it's crazy
oh most of us will probably have reacted
by just moving The Rook one square
forward but not live on he uh allows
white to capture the rook and uh okay so
now I mean this is crunch time for ding
um they've made the critical move 40 so
ding has all the time in the world 50
minutes to think about what he can do
and option one is capture The Rook the
other option is just to move the Rook
maybe to E4 but that feels no because
after all you can meet that with Pawn
takes Pawn attacking the queen so
there's nothing for it he has to capture
that Rook he has to allow
black to cut take back
The Rook on F4 with a pawn
yeah I think he missed I think he missed
E5 I I don't think he saw this move and
was hoping that Levon wouldn't find it I
think he just missed it and we are very
likely to see a trade of Brooks the
knight's gonna move back either to E5 or
to C5 notice that if it moves back to E5
black and push his C Pawn forward to C5
and I also think that there's a pretty
likely outcome of this game which is
some sort of liquidation where black
trades the sea Pawn for the Deep on and
the overall Pawn structure remains
relatively symmetrical so the e-ball bar
claims total equality I think that's a
fair assessment but since move 40 has
been played the players will settle down
into a deep think and uh we will settle
down into a break but before we do
there's a very exciting event mark your
calendars for bullet brawl Arenas which
are coming back to your screens starting
January 28th one week from now titled
players will compete in a two hour arena
with 2 500 on the line watch as your
your favorite streamers battle it out in
monthly bullet brawl Arenas starting
this coming well not tomorrow but the
Saturday after next Saturday January
28th use x Glam brawl
b-r-a-w-l in the chat for all the
details all right folks well the details
of round six of Tata steel is that a
couple of games have finished but a lot
of games are still ongoing and we don't
have any certainty in most of them so
you will not want to miss the action as
the games enter their fourth hour okay
folks as we look at that beautiful
playing haul we will be back with more
round six Tata Steel action in just a
couple of minutes
when I say chess what's the first word
that comes to your mind uh the musical
and of course the board game fantastic
okay it's just a sport absolutely very
competitive known worldwide uh battle of
wits to the highest degree I imagine
this is the best interview I've ever
given howdy sir
I'm doing great are you an important
phone call
okay that's not the first time I've had
people hang up for me thank you
thank you I appreciate it it's chess a
sport intellectually yes okay
kind of like the same type of sport
physically that NASCAR is okay does that
make sense I've actually never heard
that comparison as a guy who's been in
chess my whole life that's a great
comparison hi sir do you play chess
oh speak French okay
hey that guy was walking on passant
[Applause]
chess chess yes like the gates yes I can
beat you in chess if they beat me I'll
give you ten dollars ten ten if you beat
me I
a bit
okay I love it okay I'm gonna move my
Pawn out I don't know what you're doing
I do know what I'm doing I don't know
what I'm doing it's all right that's all
right I don't know what I'm doing in
life
okay
all right bro this Checkmate oh
who's Mate who's made bro I will
unbelievable you got 30 seconds for me
quick interview come on you look like a
chess player you play chess go ahead and
play chess okay when I say chess what's
the first thing that comes to your mind
winning
foreign
of these three things one of them is
real
it's dancing chess climbing chess boxing
chest climbing just climbing chest
dancing climbing chest climbing chess
books chest boxing chess boxing you
nailed it okay am I right for real you
nailed it seriously yeah of of the two
of us one of us is a World Chess boxing
champion which one do you think it is
him with him the guy with the camera
yeah I'd like to say you but I'm gonna
go with Mr Man over the back okay easy
no he's not I mean he does get he tried
to hit another guy earlier so oh my God
she didn't even hesitate from now on
will you stop making me do things in New
York
and Toronto where it's cold can we do
every on the street episode from here
from now on
my Lord
[Music]
foreign
day in the seaside resort town of Wake
On Zay here in round six of Tata steel
but the temperature on the board could
not be higher and we see Magnus Carlson
there the world champion he's been
scuffling he's on two out of five and he
tried to defeat Jordan van Forest of the
black pieces he unbalanced the game
successfully but the Dutch Grandmaster
held his own and we are about to get a
peaceful result in this game Magnus has
initiated a repetition to move the
overview Rook be one check kind of like
we thought King C6 and The Rook will
come back to A1 King will come back to
B7 and on and on we go on the
merry-go-round
we're about to get a draw yeah we are
and King goes to C7 The Rook will just
keep on checking the king for as long as
it can
and there you go the players will
probably be playing these moves quite
quickly from now on but no Jordan is
taking his time he's considering every
possibility
it would be funny right it would be kind
of sure
well we've been kind of joking a little
bit that is Magnus well not joking we'd
be kind of assuming that Magnus is the
one playing for the win I do wonder
whether Jordan is actually gonna put his
King on D6 and say no no no draw for you
today
76 King D6 probably was losing to Rook
A1
but you're always worth double checking
with as much time as they get on move 40
which is 50 minutes to be exact you've
got enough time to triple check Jordan
kind of looking over at the Arbiter
saying all right come over here we need
to claim the draw we've got to draw to
make
Agnes Carlson Yobe is gonna stay on
minus one through six rounds he does not
succeed in pulling out one of his
vintage endgame wins and I think all
credit should be yielded to Jordan van
Forest he held his only I'll just
composure and particularly I'm impressed
with how he handled the final stage of
this end game after Magnus played Bishop
D5 that Rook end game was not easy to
navigate and he did so with confidence
and with Verve and Magnus never really
had a real shot at winning the game
now he uh played with great accuracy and
I also kind of want to highlight the
moment where he played B4 I mean it was
a move that took me by surprise but once
it was on the board it made perfect
sense it was simplifying move it made
his position easy and uh like like you
kind of said he's handled last stages of
the game with 100
accuracy just complete Perfection there
it is not easy to play a move like that
against Magnus Carlson we talk about the
Magnus effect so often the subconscious
desire to play it safe uh to not take
risks if you're his opponent but Jordan
he's worked for Magnus he knows him very
well and he's just he just strikes me as
someone who believes in his own skill
Jordan has one taught a steal and as we
see them analyzing the game we talked
about this yesterday I love this
particular site just the sight of the
players sharing critical moments after
the game and being friendly to each
other this is what professional chess is
all about brutal competition during the
game but professionalism and uh just
warmth after the game
yeah uh yeah I have this kind of
philosophy chassis chess Life Is Life
and as soon as the clock stops I mean
you just have to go back to normal you
have to go back and just shift that
Warrior mindset and uh draw and I think
we're going to also see a draw between
Anish giri and Arjun aragaisi who just
really pledged stupendously to hold
quite a very well quite extremely
difficult position I mean we saw the
Indian teenager just pull out all the
stops and find some amazing defensive
moves and uh he did it he achieved The
Impossible and uh the final position
complete dead draw and the player is
just discussing how they could have
improved sharing their thoughts on
perhaps maybe even some winning attempts
for a niche
I mean Arch and just showing the entire
arsenal of skills he's drawn all six of
his games but uh that this really it
could not have been a more impressive
start for the Indian youngster Wesley so
he's also drawn all of his games
although that might change today and yet
the Arc of their tournaments and the
type of games they've played has been
different Arjun just surviving some
incredible preparation by Anish Gary who
is going to regret uh the preparation
not leading to a victory but that
doesn't mean it was wasted you know you
still got to do what you got to do and
good preparation doesn't always
guarantee a win especially against a
beast like Arjun who is in such good
tactical form this tournament he managed
to avoid blundering he managed his time
very well and even when he did get into
time pressure he found a way to force
the queen trade and he used his only
passed Pawn on C3 to generate just
enough counter play to hold the draw in
The Rook end game what are results
and that leaves us with only three more
games one of which I think is about to
finish as well
okay and uh one thing I saw in the
camera is that poem is still in the
playing venue you know he's loves chess
so much that he just wants to be there
and wants to be looking at everyone
else's games and we also see Max
vermerdam uh one of the competitors in
the Challenger section pacing up and
down huh well of the three games that we
have remaining Wesley so is going to win
his game against Vincent kymer who
messed up for the second day in a row a
position in which we thought is a hairs
breath away from holding the draw we
will uh break that down for you at some
point just want to recap the other two
positions to the right of that we've got
a very sharp position the only game in
which the Queens are still on the board
dingley Ren
allowing Levon to trade a pair of Rooks
with E5 and it appears now that the
worst is behind Levon I think that game
is also going to end in a draw the
players will probably find some way to
repeat moves but that's definitely worth
looking at and prognananda another
superb defensive effort as his piece
activity I think is more than enough to
hold the drop which game should we look
at first I think the prod game is likely
to end in the next two or three minutes
so shall we perhaps take a one more look
at that end game definitely let's go
there and then afterwards I definitely
want to hit sir ding Loren against
levonne aronian because that one looks
very exciting
well off we go very briefly to the
abdicator of game and as my intuition
was screaming this I think is just a
dead draw and the reason why it may seem
like white has a nasty check on F5 here
and why are you still up a pawn but in
the event of Knight F5 black just inches
the king up to G6 and the big issue is
that G4 would give you some chances if
not Rook takes H3 Rook D6 and simply
Knight back to E6 Black's construction
is watertight there are no mating
threats am I missing anything no I mean
that looks absolutely safe and sound
there you know the Knight is secured by
The Pawn on F7 every piece is nearly
protecting each other I mean it's good
going
um and of course you know I love this
construction of the Rook on the third
rank cutting off the white king and
there is an immediate threat on the
board of the night coming to E4 as you
pointed out so I don't think that can be
allowed so what happens if white stops
it so we looked at lines where whites
went aggressively and sacrificed the
pawn
and well the problem is this
another Fork now this is this is all
right then it's over just a draw
yeah yeah nothing nothing to look at
here I think we can very safely and
Trust the final couple of moves to
Prague it's just a question of when I
mean Notre Beck is thinking but there
isn't much left to think about it I
think it's just a matter of finding the
best way to force repetition or to force
a draw but the result is not in question
we will bring you this result when it
comes up but for the time being we
definitely should go straight to dingley
wren's slugfest against Lavon aronian
basically we have two games left this
one is is about to end and Wesley's
trying to squeeze out a win
is levonaronian trying to take over the
initiative
that's the big question
it suddenly it looks that way I mean
let's not disregard the black queen
sitting there on E2 I mean that is a
fearsome piece I mean first of all I'm
thinking is the an immediate threat of
actually black capturing that night on
E5 and then snatching off the pawn on G4
and if that's a threat then I would do
something about it or maybe I can't do
something about it
yeah I don't think well I guess there's
Queen C4
but black can just respond to the check
on E1 that 997 is is a very powerful
defensive piece it's guarding the Rook
now one way I think the game could end
quickly is in the event of Queen takes
Pawn on C7
now black does have Rook takes E5 but
black also has check and then check on
e4
and if white declines the repetition
with Knight to F3
well I just have a hard time believing
that black can possibly be worse with
this Knight permanently tied down and
pinned I mean even a move like Knight C6
uh should be enough to hold the draw
here for black I I was also thinking of
Rook G5 when you mentioned
hello yeah exactly I am not one to miss
my words you know and then after that my
F5 yeah
I love situations when both of these
pieces are hanging but both survive on
account of pins just a very
aesthetically pleasing
position that's a lovely tactical vision
can white hold in this position
uh
I don't see it I don't
probably there is something there
probably there's some Queen
some way to meander the queen around and
hold it this is not worth it I mean ding
is not going to do this he's going to go
King G1 and my prediction my strong
feeling is that we are going to get a
repetition of this sword maybe not Queen
takes C7 but I think the game is going
to end with a sequence of Queenie one
Queenie Fortune
yeah I agree with you I I would not take
the risk of Knight F3 I mean dingers
have rejected all the draw possibilities
here I think his King is so unsafe that
he has to just accept the inevitable and
uh what happens if you go Queen C1 to
stop the queen getting into E1 I wanted
to kind of look at what happens if uh
like a la sorry white allows Rook takes
night
um
I think it's still a draw I think
everything here is some sort of a
Perpetual because well obviously the
king should make a Mad Dash for the
center of the board but see the problem
is that black doesn't even have to make
the Perpetual black is an exchange a
pawn for the exchange so White's not
even up material should the queen
capture on H5 with check then y will be
the one down material because E5 will
also fall
no this is this is out of the question I
think for white it's only black can win
this
okay rookie five is really a threat
it is a guitar okay it's a threat
and uh well I think I probably would
play Queen takes Pawn if I were ding
just uh just force a situation and uh
Force Levon to take a draw but uh Lavon
and ding both have plenty of time and uh
plenty of possibilities to consider and
uh so this one is very sharp should we
head over to Wesley's game because let's
go that looked like it was going to be a
draw and then we kind of saw that things
had gone terribly wrong for Vincent
they did and Vincent just he's just off
and he's playing very well in the
stretches but then in critical moments
and time pressure he's getting nervous
he handled the middle game pressure
extremely well but let's rewind about 10
moves to move 33 or so we uh left the
position here we were discussing a move
like F6 and we thought that Vincent
should be able to hold instead he tries
to play very concretely he goes Knight
to B1 inviting Wesley to take and pushes
his Pawn down to B3 but Wesley just
brings his King up and says boy where
are you going because I can go Knight D2
the moment you move your knight back
from B1
yeah Wesley just fiance's Bishop what
did Vincent just do
this is oh oh breaking stuff
anyway and Knight takes B3 this might be
what Vincent missed the bishop is
counter-attacked
oh oh man
this this is uh so painful for Vincent
you know twice he's been so close to
rescuing a draw from Bad positions and
close but no cigar
look at how Wesley handles his minor
pieces he says okay you're gonna take my
C4 Pawn but not before you give away
your main Defender the bishop leaving
yourself with a lame Knight that will
not be able to stop white from creating
multiple past pawns on the king side I
think this is completely winning
but Wesley still has to demonstrate a
little bit of precision I would start
with the move Ting E4 and then just just
F4 g4h510 I think it's really as simple
as that
I mean you just have to follow the
guiding principle of uh outside past
pawns you know just got a result and we
do have a result I just saw that the
game between nordebec and pragnananda
has ended in a draw
and the game did continue as you said uh
nor do Beck choosing to repeat the
position by giving checks to the black
king and another game that I suspect
will also end very shortly is the game
between dingleren and levonne Ronin
because ding did in fact capture that
pawn on C7 and
yes
it's about to end we should we should
definitely go to that game
it is gonna finish soon and ding has put
his King on H2 after the check
and of course Lavon well he has a very
fine Queen sitting there on E2
threatening to capture the F2 Pawn so
nothing forward you have to
protect the F2 pawn move the king across
yeah you literally have there's just
nothing else you can do you can give a
check on B8
but that actually loses the game to King
H7 lavon's board he knows this game is
decided you can play Queen takes C7 and
allow a draw by Perpetual that way just
as long as you don't go up to H3 for
reasons I'm gonna let the audience
figure out
so it's really a choice of how you want
the position to repeat itself but I
don't think ding is going to take a long
time here there's nothing left to
calculate no there really isn't and uh
there we see Dean sitting by himself
and uh I'm suspecting King G2 King G1
take the Knight anything's possible but
but why does Queen B8 lose
I mean if so we're really trying so hard
King H7 and then he goes King G2 why why
would it lose can we Enlighten everyone
for sure so I think the reason is
because it relinquishes the attack on
the night and it allows the Knight to
roam about the cabin maybe it doesn't
lose maybe this is still a draw I was
under the impression that Knight C6 here
is an incredibly nasty move because if
you could deflect the Knight then you
win with Queen takes G4 and Rook H
fibrook H1 I suppose
that white has a move here that holds
things together it's probably oh it's
Queen C8 oh this is hilarious and queen
F5 somehow holds the draw okay my
Miracle my Miracle so if ding has a
masochistic streak then this is what
he's gonna do
if he does it then he should take the
draw within a minute
oh no no you don't want to do that you
don't want to walk that type rope but
you need to just play it safe to be easy
on our nerves
this actually has the potential to be
the shortest round of Tata steel thus
far it really depends on how quickly
kymer accepts the inevitable and there
we go ain't G2 at this point ding has
accepted the inevitable
and another peaceful result and another
great game yo I mean this was a rich
positional affair with both players
playing very ambitiously ding declining
repetition multiple times
and he did everything he could but Lavon
has been in great form this tournament
he's been so sharp as we see the
handshake and the peaceful result is
signed
yeah I have to say I can't fault the
players I mean it was a real struggle a
real fighting draw I mean both sides
just handled the complications perfectly
I'd really can't pinpoint any moment
where either side had a decisive
Advantage I just think it was very very
well played and when both sides are
playing exceptionally well
the result is nearly always going to be
a draw
actually
most of the time especially when you've
got players as solid as these yeah and
uh there you see the players analyzing
sharing their brief thoughts and a quick
signing of the score sheets and they are
off to enjoy
if I can say is the playing call very
close to the hotel lodgings
um I think it's as far as I remember if
they're still staying at the hotel zedo
Inn which is the the nice hotel yeah the
the only like really nice hotel in town
it's about a 10-15 minute walk but it's
so windy it's cold and that walk it's
just you know you have to layer up
because
wacon says even colder than Amsterdam
because it's obviously a a Seaside town
is it one of those walks where if you
walk in the right direction you get
there in two minutes but if you walk
again exactly
half an hour
laboriously just dragging your feet now
the players might get transportation
from the hotel I don't know how it works
in tata Steel
uh but I know that some players they
prefer to walk and in general you'll be
I love walking during tournaments I
think it's very necessary to get fresh
air it's kind of a cliche but it's so
true I think if you measured my
tournament performances the tournaments
where I just sat in the hotel and was
lazy you know those tend to lead to more
blunders and less sharp play
yeah uh in general in general I kind of
agree with you and is what I would
advise but I do remember that my very
best tournament it was actually in
Gibraltar and there was a free day and
this was uh the one and only time that
they tried a free day and on that free
day the weather was so bad we did
nothing just lay in bed all day and
that's very unusual and then I ended up
nearly winning every single game
afterwards so wow well it might be the
exception to the rule generally I'm like
you I like to have that fresh air I like
to have that morning stroll I I just
it's nice to sharpen the senses before
you get in and uh play some great chess
yeah I mean at the US Championship I try
to hit the treadmill every day
unfortunately
uh day one I'll be in the gym morning 9
A.M day two more like 10 a.m day three
maybe I'll make it right before the
round and starting day four I'm just you
know ordering food into my hotel room
and I'm going straight to the tournament
Hall so it's kind of easy to lose your
discipline as the tournament progresses
and you get more tired
um one player who has not lost his
discipline in the least is Wesley so and
he is going to win the game the result
is not in question at all
Vincent might resign here that's not out
of the question he's gonna probably play
a couple more moves but I think yeah
King E6 I mean she's gonna try and what
we're gonna explain in a second why this
is so hopeless the bottom line is that
Wesley just advances his pawns and wins
but Wesley just keeps pushing and
pushing and pushing and for some of the
younger players that incredible
resilience that grit can be very tough
to handle
it certainly can and there we see Wesley
advancing his g-pawn he is getting ready
to advance the age pawn and create an
outside passport and it's not just that
he can do that at leisure he can even
Advance the F Pawn and push that one off
the board
um I mean he can maximize this position
to its full potential the only thing
that I would say is if the Knight steps
to D5 and attacks the bishop I do feel
that the bishop should remain on this
long diagonal just primarily to keep an
eye on any kind of porn moves such as F6
just prevent that from happening exactly
let's let's play through a couple of
scenarios uh as for how the game could
could end I think Heimer is gonna play
Knight T5 I think it's very very likely
Wesley's gonna drop his Bishop pack now
I want to give two illustrative lines
first of all if black tries to set up
some sort of a blockade this never works
because after onpass Knight F6 white
automatically takes goes King D5 and the
three on one uh decides the game so
that's out of the question as of course
is F6 for the same reason kymer will
probably play C4 and to this Wesley will
automatically respond to F4 black can
initiate the last line of defense the
Maginot Line can be set up with Knight
E7 fortunately Knights are terrible
Defenders and the win is as simple as H5
breakthrough then Intermezzo and after
GH I think around a position like this
is where Vincent is likely to resign the
king ambles up to G5 and the pawn
promotes to a queen okay Knight A4 by
Vincent basically the same thing
as he gets up from his chair he doesn't
want to look at the position
yeah he's like I'm just assisted by this
this is often what happens when you know
the situation is hopeless you're just
like okay
just make a move and uh maybe something
will happen maybe something won't it
does not matter and uh yeah I thought
your F5 move was especially important
because the last thing you want to allow
a king and Knight to orchestrate is a
blockade as long as your pawns just
control and dominate the Black Knight
everything is fine
no that's that's a great point and
that's actually why you want your Bishop
on anyone you want to dominate the key
squares along that long diagonal and
reinforce your E5 Pawn but mainly you
want to prevent you want to take the
sting out of the move F5 Wesley
casually comes back and writes down the
move and what I like is that the players
don't take unnecessary time Wesley has
been playing quickly and that's because
he's already calculated everything he
doesn't have to recalculate on every
move he knows what the winning approach
is and I think he's going to play Bishop
A1 pretty quickly here
I I think so too and I actually think
that now the night has moved to the edge
of the board I don't even think it's
very important that he has to hold the
long diagonal I think he can put his
Bishop more or less on any Square as
long as he's got P2 and it's going to be
winning
um so you can't go wrong
no literally everything was I think
Vincent's actual idea is to meet Bishop
A1 with C4 the sort of last ditch
attempt to muddy the waters
and try to drag White's King back so
that you can use your own King to go
well go after some of White's kingside
Pawns
so yes we could bring up that board
again I think we can predict how the
game is going to finish Bishop A1 C4
okay and then I'm predicting f
F4
F4 I'll go C3
and uh then I can give a check with F5
I will drop back
and then the king will step back to D3
to catch the pawn
simple and winning I was going to
propose an alternative I think
in this position before F4 there's also
the move Bishop to D4
completely dominating the Knight
Vincent they play C3 and now you
you try ah you drop back and after King
D5 I think you win with a very timely H5
yeah
just take it there's no way that H Pawn
can be caught
not even close the Knight could not be
on a worst possible this is literally
the worst spot on the entire chessboard
and the Knight has found a way to occupy
it
this is likely I think your F4 F5
approach is simpler and just as winning
so
but can we just put up that pattern
where the bishop is on D4 and the Knight
was on A4 because I just want all our
viewers at home to kind of just get that
pattern in their minds because this is
so important just look at it the Knight
on A4 completely dominated does not have
one single Square
and it's one of those things that if you
don't know it you might not catch those
fleeting moments when you're given the
opportunity to catch the night
and another cool detail to piggyback off
of that is let's say for example that
black does not bother with King D5 black
goes back to E7 you don't even need to
take C3 you can you can run the King
around and what's fascinating is that
although the Knight has an escape square
look at the extent of the domination if
the Knight goes back to A14 B3 traps it
Knight D1 is a symmetrical reflection
about I don't know the x-axis the y-axis
been a while since I did calculus but
the Knight is just as trapped on D1 as
it would be on A4 and this is the power
of the bishop this is why Bishops are
better than Knights if you take every
Knight versus Bishop situation I think
the consensus the jury is still out but
I'm siding with Team Bishop personally
yeah
I mean I I'm hesitant to come to a
conclusion but I'm also favoring the
bishop and I just love that line you
just showed you know just when black
things they've got the night out you're
like no
get back in there and uh A1 on the board
yeah Wesley knows exactly what to do and
I I are we expecting a resignation now
from Vincent or do you think he will
just try C4 I think he will play C for
fun yeah yeah I think you will play C4
and I think after Bishop D4
he might play C3
and then I think King D3 will I actually
think if I had to make I'm gonna go on a
limb I think the final position is going
to be Wesley giving up that Bishop on D4
and promoting the H Pawn
so I'm not sure why Vincent seems as
calm as he is I mean the game is over
and he's just sipping his water he was
walking over to see the challengers
games by the way that's what he was
doing
well the Fate is and well his uh fate is
out of his hands you know Wesley knows
that he's winning there's nothing he can
do so why waste any energy being angry I
mean you've got many more rounds to play
just uh focus on that well that's my
philosophy anyhow it's it's a wholesome
attitude but I would be you know huffing
and Puffin and showing everything
um on my face
I remember I mean through the years I've
gotten a lot better at hiding my
emotions but I just remember a game in
2015 I was playing Alex chabalov former
US champion in the U.S Championship I
played a brilliant game and then I did
the thing where you know you make the
second move of the variation
it was plus 11. one move and I win and I
made a move that I was thinking about
from a different position he immediately
realized that it gives up all of my
advantage in fact after that I'm
basically worse
and I was just inconsolable I was like
I can't even describe what I was doing I
was putting my head in my hands and I
was like making sounds and I almost
slammed the table like sometimes the
emotion just you're just so mad that it
comes pouring out of you you know in the
classical game
yeah no I I've been there myself you
know I know how that feels I I think I
almost burst into tears at one point you
know because I I got so nervous it was a
crunch game
Final Round And if I if I won I was
going to get a medal in the European
Women's Championship uh a draw would
have been fantastic because it just
meant easy qualification to the world
championship
and uh I don't know what happened but I
just had like some kind of mini meltdown
on it ends up playing terrible chess
like I literally a dodgy line lines that
I know really really well and I ended up
blundering everything and I had the end
of it I was just like you I I just could
not stop the tears and I was like why
did I do this I mean the emotion gets
too much
um but in recent years I've become
better at controlling that and
probably the extent of my anger will
probably it will be uh like giving a
very limp handshake
sometimes kind of stomping off
yeah no totally totally relate to that
our uh lovely producer Vic uh big shout
out by the way this has been a great
production don't want to jinx it he
brings up an interesting point uh in our
chat here which is uh he asks have you
ever lost the game and the opponent
starts analyzing and you just don't feel
like it and wants to sign the score she
can walk away the interesting thing
is that previously when my opponent
would ask me to look over the game I
would always say yes and then there was
a point at which I played a game I
offered my opponent to analyze and he
said no I'd rather rest I was like wait
a second you can actually say no you are
allowed to go rest after a game and now
I'm very comfortable declining like if
there's enough time between the first
and the second round because in the U.S
32 rounds a day I will analyze the game
but if not I won't be shy about just
saying I thought it was a good game but
I'd rather just get some rest so yeah
problem solved especially if I lost like
you're under no obligation to you don't
have to force yourself to analyze like
it's okay to go back and take time for
yourself after a painful game
yeah absolutely I agree with you
um I I definitely as a rule of thumb
um if I'm playing two rounds a day I am
not analyzing at all even if I've had an
early finish actually because I'd
actually rather use that time and just
go back to the room rest close my eyes
get ready for the next game and I I do
say that
um
also
I have uh refused to analyze just
because I lost
I mean you're upset you know you're
allowed to rest and to recover on your
own and sometimes the last thing you
want is your opponent run again how much
more they saw you know
yeah I know sometimes it's just an
exercise and misery just to go over your
game you just think okay I'm not ready
for it just now and then afterwards you
know you kind of do talk to them
um about the game and here comes C4 okay
my prediction aging pretty well if I
make sure I'm watching off Bishop Bishop
D4 uh D4 are we gonna see F4 they all
win we're gonna see Bishop D4 I've
played Wesley I think six or seven times
in classical chess I think of of all the
super jams I've played him the most and
I think I have the best understanding of
what makes him tick Wesley loves peace
domination he loves moves like Bishop D4
that just bring the hammer down on his
opponent
but watch me say all of this and then he
goes for your recommendation F4 yeah
Next Step good very good
very methodical by Wesley doesn't rush
just takes his time
he's I can guarantee you he's
recalculating the line with King D3 King
D5 and H5 making sure because the Knight
it can be a very tricky piece sometimes
the Knight can stop a past Pawn with a
check to the king but with a knight on
A4 and the King on C2 you can't even get
a check in two moves and there he goes
King C2 King D3
and in fact talking about that
configuration
um when a king is diagonally placed
across the night next to the night as in
one square away
can I give a check it's very very
difficult and here he comes can goes to
D5 horn is going to push to H5
now you can take on C3 here but that
would be highly an advisable because
that pawn end game is probably a draw so
Wesley one final pass through
but not necessary insignificant just go
for gold do it
he knows
he does and there's no other move
actually because otherwise black will
actually go C2 so at this point you're
as you said yesterday in for a penny in
for a pound
you've got to do it
absolutely and uh yeah he's just taking
a moment just to recheck his thoughts I
mean there is a Fail-Safe you know
um you can make a move like F4 because
C2 will be met by Bishop E3 but you
don't want to do that you know H5
I'll tell you what he's probably double
checking I think he's not even double
checking C2 it's more he's making sure
that after H5 trade and King E6 he can
actually trap the Knight because this
King C2 King B3 pattern is pretty darn
unique but C2 by Vincent and we got it
this is exactly how the game is gonna
end
yeah King takes one
and age six and that's going to be that
it is
and yeah he snaps off that pawn and uh
King takes Bishop are we gonna see the
game continue are we gonna see a
resignation and it's ready it's over
Vincent resigns Wesley takes his first
point in tata steel Masters
wow I mean just wow Wesley is Relentless
the guy never quits guy had a very
lackluster start but this was a vintage
Wesley game pressure all game long from
the very first moves there was a point
at which we thought Vincent held but
Vincent losing in a very similar manner
to his game against aronia and yesterday
just when we think he stabilized the
situation he makes a huge mistake
missing I don't even know what giving
away the A4 Pawn for no reason and the
German youngster Yogi is just this is
just a sign of some really really
difficult form he's gonna have to step
it up in a big way if he wants to avoid
one of those disaster tournaments yeah I
was just this it doesn't seem like he's
making too many mistakes but when the
mistake does happen it seems to be
colossal I mean we saw that yesterday in
his game against leonoronian and we saw
big blonde in the end game and then now
we saw the same you know they were game
changers and uh there we see today's
results and uh we see Vincent shaking
his head yeah he he needs to stabilize
he needs to study the ship so tomorrow I
think he will have the white pieces and
uh we'll see something solid and he just
has to hold his nerve
that's exactly what he has to do and we
have two decisive games Wesley wins as
we just signed Fabiano caruana just a
lovely game against gukesh that was
pretty one-sided and Kesh and kymer they
are the two players alongside Magnus
Carlsen are really having uh the
roughest go of it for Jordan Ben Forrest
a bright spot today as he remains on
minus two but holds the world champion
in a very clinical game with the white
pieces let's take a look at the
standings which really haven't changed
all that much the only big difference
Yogi as Magnus remains in the bottom
half of the tournament cross stable
Fabiano caruana has burst onto the scene
and now is tied with anishikiri her
second place half a point behind
notrebec who cements and maintains his
half point lead over this incredible
field of players
yeah no one can rest after all everyone
is playing a difficult game and uh let's
have a look at tomorrow's round seven
matchups
and uh
let's there we go we see it uh gukash
faces off against Wesley so and I poured
kakesh he's been having a tough time of
it lately and he will meet someone who
will be riding high after today's
Victory Wesley so and another notable
um battle is between Magnus Carlson
against Richard Rapport I love seeing
these two Jewel
oh me too this is gonna be awesome
yeah Magnus with the white pieces and I
just can't wait to see what kind of
unconventional opening Richard report
will choose and uh talking about
unconventional openings we have Prague
against Jordan van for East as well I
mean again
you saw Jordan he actually he stabilizes
he had a draw after a painful loss in
game five but now he faces someone who's
just in the ascendant Prague that would
be a close close battle and uh of course
the leader tournament leader Nordy back
Abdul sataurov Heath has the black
pieces against Arjun erag icy
indeed he does that's a great summary
and just looking at these mouth-watering
matchups it's like every day promises to
be a so exciting aronian gear is going
to be a great game for Magnus Carlson as
the tournament will reach its halfway
point tomorrow there is still time to
make a comeback but it really has to
start with the white pieces he held he
was held to a draw today not the end of
the world but tomorrow against a Richard
report who has been very up and down the
world champion will have to strike to
get back to 50 and for norterbeck abusso
tour of a very very difficult challenge
an on-form Argent era guys who now has
the white thesis who hasn't lost a game
and who has displayed phenomenal
defensive prowess throughout the
tournament but can Arjun eragisi have a
game where he goes on the offensive can
he stop he Uzbek Talent Furious run
through the top of the tournament cross
stable this folks is coming your way on
Friday wait today is Friday Friday
Saturday yeah I actually thought today
was Thursday today is Friday so it will
be Saturday uh tomorrow Saturday the
matchups that we just saw the round as
per usual will be coming your way bright
and early in the U.S 5 a.m Pacific Time
8 A.M New York time and 2 p.m a more
civilized hour Central European Time we
will be bringing you the commentary
tomorrow as well yovi back to you for
your final thoughts on what was yet
another Super exciting day of action
yeah what can I say every single game
had it all that was so much fight and
absolutely everything I mean we've been
spoiled I mean yes it was a peaceful
round in terms of results but boy did
the players put absolutely everything
into it and I've loved every second of
it so far and Dania it's been an
absolute pleasure commentating with you
you just made the hours whiz past so
thank you
well thank you I can really say the same
about you this has been a great pleasure
these past two days I'm excited for the
weekend tomorrow is going to bring more
action and more Intrigue and more
fascinating openings and interesting
battles but for now uh we'd like to
thank everybody and again we had tens of
thousands of you across the platforms
cheering on your favorite player and our
producer Bick for another lovely
broadcast this was Flawless this was
great so happy Friday everybody we will
see you tomorrow bright and early and
for now this was Grandmaster Daniel
narditsky and international master
yobanka houska from Tata steel chess we
will see you tomorrow for round seven so
long
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign